nous nous retrouvons mes chers collègues
cet après-midi pour continuer notre
cycle d'audition sur la rentrée scolaire
et après notre rencontre de ce matin
avec le directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire monsieur Édouard
geffret nous accueillons les
représentants des organisations
syndicales d'enseignants du premier du
second degré public donc mesdames et
messieurs je tiens tout d'abord à vous
remercier de vous être rendu disponible
en une période que nous savons très
chargée pour vous
et avant de vous laisser la parole pour
recueillir vos impressions et
observations sur la rentrée scolaire
2023-2024 j'ai une ou deux questions à
vous poser mais je serais très bref
puisque je vous ai demandé la même chose
la modification du calendrier visant à
replacer au mois de juin les épreuves de
spécialité du baccalauréat
implique-t-elle une réorganisation
importante de vos enseignements et cette
modification du calendrier des épreuves
vous semble-t-elle être la bonne
solution pour maintenir la motivation
des lycéens sur l'ensemble de l'année
scolaire j'avais plein plein plein
d'autres questions mais mes collègues en
auront plein d'autres donc je vais vous
donner la parole à chacune des
organisations syndicales présentes donc
j'ai convenu avec vous pour une durée
environ de 6 minutes au départ c'était
10 je vais en informer collègues mais
dans le cadre d'avoir quelque chose de
beaucoup plus interactif et dynamique et
que chacun puisse prendre la parole et
que vous ayez le temps de répondre aux
questions vous avez bien voulu
l'accepter et je vous en remercie
vraiment beaucoup donc en respectant
l'ordre de représentativité nous aurons
d'abord pour la syndicale unitaire donc
la FSU madame Sophie vénétiquet et
Madame Ghislaine David secrétaire
national pour le syndicat des
enseignants de l'INSA madame Laurence
Hope et Elisabeth Jamin chargé de
mission pour la Fédération Nationale de
l'Enseignement de la culture et de la
formation professionnelle Force Ouvrière
monsieur Christophe Lalande secrétaire
fédéral pour le Syndicat général de
l'Éducation nationale CFDT madame
Sandrine Dumas et madame Claire Marion
pour la CGT du action madame enablons
closides secrétaire national et Monsieur
Yannick billiette secrétaire
départementale de l'Essonne et pour le
samedi pour le Syndicat national des
lycées collège école du supérieur
monsieur Jean-Rémy Girard président
national et Monsieur Xavier périnée
Marquet membres du bureau national et
pour la Fédération du Sud éducation
madame Maud valejas co secrétaire
fédéral donc je vous laisse la parole et
puis au fur et à mesure
nous irons jusqu'à
fédération SUD-éducation merci merci je
vais commencer pour la FSU Ghislaine
David on va commencer je vais commencer
par le premier degré et puis ma collègue
voilà pourra répondre à nos questions
sur le bac mais ne vous enfin ne vous
inquiétez pas vous aurez une réponse
mais en tout cas ce sera pas la mienne
oui alors on va essayer de faire
synthétique et court ce qui pose
problème en cette rentrée c'est une
rentrée très compliquée et
chaque année c'est de plus en plus
compliqué je pense qu'il faut que vous
soyez conscient que on a des personnels
qui vont de plus en plus mal et une
école qui va de plus en plus mal c'est
bien évidemment
il y a certaines raisons qui qui
poussent à cela notamment le manque
d'enseignants alors si dans le premier
degré la première semaine de la rentrée
est plus liée à la carte scolaire et à
l'ajustement aux ajustements de rentrer
en fermeture et aux ouvertures c'est
maintenant qu'on commence à sentir les
difficultés du manque d'enseignants
notamment avec le manque de remplaçant
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
simple la semaine dernière mais je
pourrais en prendre plein d'autres dans
une école du Val d'Oise où il y avait
deux enseignantes où il y a deux
enseignantes qui sont à mi-temps elles
n'ont personne pour compléter leur
mi-temps parce que il y a pas
suffisamment d'enseignants la directrice
n'a pas sa décharge direction parce
qu'il y a pas d'enseignants donc il
manque des enseignants dans ces écoles
là donc ce qu'on va avoir dans les
prochaines semaines parce que les pour
faire pour mettre des enseignants devant
les classes les dazen recrutent sur leur
brigade de remplacement ils ont des des
brigades des remplaçants qui peuvent qui
peuvent effectuer des remplacements des
remplacements courts ou des
remplacements longs et là il se trouve
que beaucoup d'enseignants sont mis
directement dans des classes à l'année
donc ils ne sont plus disponibles pour
assurer les déplacements les
remplacements courts chez nous dans le
1er degré on a beaucoup de remplacements
de congés maternité parce que nous
sommes une profession féminisée à 84%
mais aussi les gardent d'enfants malades
qui reviennent souvent aux femmes et
puis bien évidemment des congés malades
donc il y a vraiment une difficulté et
dans les prochaines semaines on va s'en
apercevoir et le la promesse du
président de remplacer tous les
enseignants absents ne sera pas
effectivement dans le premier degré
pareil on remarque de plus en plus de
temps de droits des personnels qui ne
sont pas respectés par les Azen
notamment sur les temps partiels ou on
accepte le temps partiel de droit mais
on n'accepte pas forcément la quotité
demandée par l'agence c'est-à-dire on
accepte on va accepter un 75% mais pas
un 50% parce que on va comme ça garder
une enseignante en plus on a des refus
de plus en plus de temps partiel et de
de disponibilité donc le système du
recrutement est sous tension vous l'avez
vu par le biais des concours on a
effectivement des concours qui enfin les
étudiants qui ne passent pas le concours
dans certaines académies les quatre
académies difficiles Créteil Versailles
Mayotte et la Guyane il y a un vrai
problème d'attractivité il manque près
de 1600 postes dans ces académies là
mais pour autant on recrute des
contractuels dans ces académies mais ce
qui nous inquiète énormément c'est qu'on
recrute aussi des contractuels dans les
académiques qui ne sont pas déficitaires
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a une tension
sur les postes dans ces académies là qui
ne sont pas liés on a pourtant de
l'attractivité dans ces académies mais
on n'a pas suffisamment d'enseignants
recrutés donc on a des contractuels qui
sont de plus en plus importants je citer
trois quatre académies puis je vois le
temps passé donc je vais m'arrêter c'est
vraiment très dur comme exercice surtout
quand on a préparé beaucoup de choses à
dire donc l'académie de Bordeaux on a
267 contractuels de recruter à ce jour
Aix-Marseille 190 contractuels Grenoble
213 contractuels ce sont des académies
qui ne sont pas des académies qui
n'attirent pas elles attirent il y a des
il y a des enseignants qui veulent et
qui veulent enseigner mais on a un
recrutement de contractuel voilà je
pourrais répondre après sur vos
questions sur les conditions
d'enseignement et notamment les
effectifs par classe
oui bonjour à toutes et à tous donc
Sophie bene cité pour le second degré
d'avoir j'ai commencé par répondre à vos
questions ça sera fait d'abord vous dire
que sur les la modification du
calendrier des épreuves de spécialité du
bac oui c'est une bonne solution c'était
la solution que nous on portait au
sniffe puisque ça va permettre de donner
une année entière pour les
apprentissages ce qui n'est pas du luxe
notamment pour les élèves les plus
fragiles et ça c'est un élément très
important à prendre en compte la
deuxième chose c'est que ça implique une
réorganisation qui a des conséquences
sur nous la façon dont on travaille
conséquence sur lesquelles pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas de réponse de
la part du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale je pense par exemple à la
question des programmes aujourd'hui on
ne sait toujours pas exactement quelle
sur quel programme on va devoir préparer
nos élèves et qu'elle va être le format
exact d'une épreuve comme le grand oral
mais je pourrais peut-être développer
par la suite quelques éléments sur sur
cette rentrée pendant le second degré
c'est une rentrée où la crise que
connaît l'éducation nationale s'aggrave
elle s'aggrave d'abord par le manque de
personnel et par la crise d'attractivité
que nos métiers continuent de connaître
alors on l'a vu et Guylaine David le
disait par le fait que les concours
n'ont pas fait le plein et pour nous
dans le second degré ça c'est
particulièrement vu à cette rentrée le
ciné s'est fait dessus la montrer grâce
au enquête de rentrer au bout d'une
semaine il manquait au moins un
professeur dans plus de la moitié des
établissements donc la promesse d'avoir
un professeur devant chaque classe à la
rentrée n'a pas été tenue et on a
assisté à un véritable bricolage
institutionnalisé puisque on a trouvé
des petites annonces de recrutement sur
Facebook on a trouvé des petites
annonces de recrutement sur les
environnements numériques de travail
vous avez des chefs d'établissement mais
je comprends très bien qu'il puisse être
en difficulté mais qui qui demande
est-ce que vous ne connaissez pas
quelqu'un qui pourrait éventuellement
venir faire cours de de français ou de
mathématiques voilà où on est
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça que nous on a on a lancé
cette enquête pour faire la vérité par
rapport au discours ministériel mais
aussi parce qu'on estime que situation
est un véritable scandale l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui n'est pas en
mesure d'assurer une rentrée en 2023
dans la septième puissance du monde et
il faut que tout le monde l'entende et
que tout le monde prenne la mesure de ce
qui va se passer d'autant plus que je le
rappelle selon les chiffres de la DARES
il va falloir recruter 329 000
enseignants premiers et second degré
confondus d'ici 2030 donc il va falloir
travailler cette question d'attractivité
on pourra y revenir par la suite je
voudrais juste ajouter un point sur
utiliser en introduction que que la
crise s'aggrave c'est pas seulement la
crise de recrutement qui qui persiste
voir qui s'aggrave c'est aussi la crise
de nos métiers pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'il y a des mesures qui sont
prises qui font du mal à nos métiers je
pense à la question du pacte du pacte
enseignant qui est aujourd'hui très
largement rejeté par nos par nos
collègues on pourra développer dans dans
les échanges mais aussi à cause des
réformes je pense ici par exemple à la
réforme de la voie professionnelle qui
là aussi fait perdre le sens du métier
et ce pourquoi on a choisi ce métier et
voilà la crise d'attractivité de nos
métiers c'est pas ce sont des chiffres
mais ce sont aussi des gens qui ne vont
pas bien ce sont les professeurs qui ne
vont pas bien et qui ne trouvent plus de
sens dans leur métier je pourrais aussi
évoquer ce qui se passe au collège mais
on aura l'occasion je pense d'y revenir
donc pour finir face à cette crise crise
d'attractivité crise du métier crise de
nos métiers ce sont de vrais problèmes
auxquels le ministre aujourd'hui apporte
de fausse réponse soit par des promesses
non tenues soit en faisant diversion en
surjouan certains sujets par des coups
politiques et médiatiques mais il nous
semble que l'éducation nationale mérite
bien plus que ça et bien mieux que ça
sur tous les sujets que j'ai cités et
bien d'autres que je pourrais
approfondir par la suite
merci beaucoup pour
[Musique]
d'avoir tenu à peu près le timing merci
pour la Fédération parce que je me suis
rendue l'une ça oui juste après
bonjour à toutes et bonjour à tous donc
Laurent sobre pour le second degré
est-ce une ça alors cette rentrée
scolaire et surtout marquée par la
promotion des décisions gouvernementales
à grand renfort de battage médiatique à
se demander qui fait sa rentrée dans la
circulaire de rentrée publiée en juillet
nous avons découvert la compilation de
toutes les annonces de l'année qui
seront mises en oeuvre dès la rentrée
2023 nous avons aussi découvert des
flyers promotionnels envoyés au
directeur d'école et au chef
d'établissement pour distribuer aux
parents comment le ferait d'un catalogue
publicitaire pour de grandes anciennes
comme car je vais laisser un petit trou
ou un terre je laisse un petit trou
pendant que le la communication
gouvernementale s'opère les vrais
problèmes de l'école ne sont pas traités
le ministre préfère mettre en avant des
sujets médiatiques ceux qui vont animer
le débat pour le SEO est avant tout
marqué par le manque de personnel au
sens large pour notre chambre
syndicalisation nous constatons encore
une fois un manque de CPE de psyen
daeh et d'enseignants dans le second
degré nous estimons à 58% le nombre de
collèges et lycées dans lesquels il
manquait au moins un professeur le jour
de la rentrée cette situation risque de
s'accentuer lorsqu'il s'agira de
remplacer les absences de moyenne ou
longue durée parce que la plupart des
pardon des remplaçants du premier comme
du second degré sont déjà en poste à
l'année en cette rentrée
par ailleurs le pacte enseignant que
nous
continuons à dénoncer prend mal mais
avec des différences entre le premier
degré les collèges les lycées généraux
et technologiques et les lycées
professionnels
le pacte notamment pour procéder au RCD
mais pas seulement détruit des
fonctionnements antérieurs les
remplacements de courte durée étaient
déjà un procédé qui existait avant sur
la base du volontariat des enseignants
et aujourd'hui il a fallu le formaliser
ce qui a braqué tout le monde parce
qu'il y avait des comment dire il y
avait dépendant on va dire comme ça pour
être court il me reste une minute donc
on interpelle aussi sur un risque
considérable celui de voir basculer les
moyens d'enseignement les moyens
d'enseignement donc la DAJ en pacte
c'est déjà le cas pour mettre en place
l'heure de français maths en 6e ou le
dédoublement français maths en seconde
pro ou les options du lycée
professionnel
mais nous allons encore faire un autre
focus il y a aussi les viscères qui sont
à nouveau fragilisés par les décisions
ministérielles il est toujours de
difficile de recruter le nombre d'AED
nécessaire non le métier ne fait
toujours pas rêver mais le risque qui
plane de mobiliser les AED pour procéder
au remplacement de courte durée
pourraient désorganiser les vies
scolaires au-delà de ça les AED qui ont
un rôle fondamental pour
identifier les situations de harcèlement
et notamment ce qu'on appelle les
signaux faibles
ne seront plus disponibles pour cette
mission qui devient prioritaire pour le
ministre mais qui est pris prioritaire
pour nous depuis longtemps pour être
efficace il nous faut des moyens humains
et financiers en vie scolaire
pour le
il faut que votre collègue
je vais vous parler de l'inclusion
scolaire alors l'inclusion des élèves en
situation de handicap ou a besoin
éducatif particulier est une autre
difficulté de cette rentrée nos
collègues particulièrement du premier
degré sont en souffrance face à des
situations qu'ils ne peuvent plus qu'ils
ne savent pas gérer on est à un point de
bascule vers un possible rejet de
l'inclusion scolaire par nos collègues
épuisés aujourd'hui l'enjeu de l'école
inclusive et de savoir quelle direction
le gouvernement va prendre le 100%
inclusion en classe ordinaire ce qui est
demandé par de nombreuses associations
de parents d'enfants handicapés ou la
scolarité en classe ordinaire et ou en
établissement médico-sociaux
osua une salle nous sommes impatients de
connaître le cap gouvernemental qui
n'est pas clairement défini les mesures
annoncées le 26 avril à la CNH
Conférence nationale du handicap sont
vagues et ne répondre et ne répondront
pas vraiment aux besoins de la nous
attendons du gouvernement qui Louvre de
vrais négociations avec les
représentants des personnels pour que
l'école inclusive ne soit pas subie ni
par les enseignants ni par les élèves et
leurs familles au quotidien nos écoles
nos collègues et nos collègues et nos
lycées manquent d'un ESH et beaucoup
d'élèves sont en attente de place on
était en établissement médico-sociaux ou
en
ULIS certaines SEGPA sont par ailleurs
bondées nous par ailleurs nous
constatons de plus en plus de
professionnels peu ou pas formés pour
des postes spécialisés de coordonnateurs
du Lys de référence scolarité rsh dans
la classe les enseignants ont besoin
d'une aide humaine pour la prise en
charge de certains élèves sur le plan
éducatif comportemental ou pédagogiques
les aesh ne peuvent pas seuls seuls
répondre à cette nécessité il faut donc
reconstituer ou consolider les Raz qui
sont essentiels pour la prise en charge
de la grande difficulté scolaire et que
nous confondons de plus en plus avec le
handicap ce qui pour le seu ça n'est pas
possible et ce ne sont pas les
injonctions pédagogiques d'un ministre
qui aideront les enseignants ne laissons
pas croire que les méthodes pédagogiques
employées aujourd'hui échouent
systématiquement alors que 70% de nos
élèves en transisème
en maîtrisant par exemple les
compétences attendues il ne faut pas il
ne faut poser la vraie question comment
prendre en charge les 30%
d'élèves pour l'école ces méthodes
échouent et ce n'est pas la suppression
des textes à trous parfois pourtant
parfois recommandé dans les adaptations
pédagogiques pour les élèves a besoin
éducatifs particuliers qui répondra à
cette question
ce n'est pas non plus on surchargeant de
cours supplémentaire les élèves en
difficulté ou en les privant de vacances
scolaires qu'on répondra à cette
question la littérature est pleine
d'exemples contraires en conclusion pour
le sui ça si le bilan de la rentrée 2023
est négative les suivants pourraient
être si le gouvernement ne répond pas
aux vraies questions quelle politique
éducatif pour faire réussir tous les
élèves quelle politique RH pour donner
de la motivation à tous les personnels
et une meilleure attractivité pour nos
métiers je vous remercie merci pour la
Fédération Nationale de l'Enseignement
et de la culture de la formation
professionnelle Force Ouvrière
donc à force Ouvrière n'oublions pas que
ça se rentrer se fait avec
les enseignants qui vont devoir
travailler deux ans de plus suite à la
réforme des retraites dont nous
demandons l'abbrogation qui a été en
période passée en force par le par le
gouvernement de même la Fnac fpfo
condamne la violence d'État qui se
déchaîne depuis des mois contre les
salariés les syndicalistes la jeunesse
et soutient toutes les initiatives
contre la répression qui s'organise en
défense des libertés démocratiques et la
justice sociale et
nous syndicats nombre de nos syndicats
et de nos adhérents seront présents par
exemple dans la manifestation de samedi
le président Macron est le ministre
Attal on multiplié en cette rentrée des
annonces que nous qualifions de
provocatrices concernant l'école
l'interdiction du port de la Baya par
exemple constitue pour nous une mesure
de diversion et de division qui vise à
détourner l'attention des vrais
problèmes et du chaos qui organisé par
le gouvernement
elle risque d'ailleurs de placer les
personnels en particulier de direction
que nous représentons en grande
difficulté faire bloc pour la laïcité
c'est avant tout pour nous agir pour
labrogation des lois anti laïques
l'arrêt des mesures de
territorialisation et de privatisation
le respect de la loi 1905 le respect du
principe à l'école publique les fonds
publics à l'école privée les fonds
privés
le président Macron a aussi indiqué
qu'il faudrait que les élèves en
difficulté et donc tout partis
d'enseignant reprennent le 20 août
[Musique]
indique en sens attaquer à la difficulté
scolaire mais il oublie de mentionner
que 2000 postes d'enseignants ont été
supprimés en cette rentrée et que lors
du premier quinquennat du président
Macron 7900 postes ont été supprimés
dans les lycées les collèges est-ce que
rétablir ces postes ne seraient pas plus
de nature à s'attaquer à la difficulté
scolaire alors que l'école manque de
tout Force Ouvrière revendique l'arrêt
des suppressions de poste les créations
de poste nécessaires
et se place au côté des personnels qui
souvent avec les parents d'élèves et les
élus se mobilisent pour la situation des
revendications
alors qu'on nous parle d'austérité de
réduire rigueur budgétaire partout et
que les droits sociaux les services
publics sont attaqués
on trouve un petit peu étonnant que dans
ce cadre
la hausse des crédits de guerre 413
milliards d'ici 2030 soit une hausse de
plus de 40%, puisse être à l'ordre du
jour le président Macron administral
pour nous ne répondent pas aux problèmes
qui se posent des sept rentrée
revendications urgente les postes on en
a parlé l'abrogation du service national
universel qui pour nous cherche à
embrigader la jeunesse et à réduire les
cours qui sont octroyés
le retrait de la réforme de la voie
professionnelle que nous revendiquons
qui vise à s'attaquer sans prendre aux
filières de la voie professionnelle
labrogation de la loi 3DS qui transfère
au collectivités les personnels adjoint
gestionnaires par exemple l'abrogation
de la loi riaque qui remet en cause la
structure traditionnelle dans le premier
degré la remise en cause du droit pour
tous les élèves à pouvoir bénéficier
d'un enseignement adapté avec le dogme
proclamé en permanence d'inclusion
scolaire systématique à ce titre nous
dénonçons les annonces concernant l'acte
2 de l'école inclusive qui vise à encore
réduire les coûts à continuer de s'en
prendre à distance des structures et des
postes adaptées et aux missions des absh
qui devraient
s'ils veulent avoir leur salaire un
petit peu augmenté prendre des missions
supplémentaires avec les are à l'image
du du pacte donc nous exigeons l'abandon
de ces mesures et le maintien
développement toute les structures et
postes spécialisés sur la question des
épreuves de spécialité nous prenons acte
du fait que le ministre a été
contraindre reculer pour autant nous
conseillons que ça ne rompons pas aux
revendications des personnels pour
rétablir le premier grade universitaire
qui permettent à tous les bacheliers de
pouvoir postuler dans la filière de leur
choix et l'obtenir ça nécessite
l'abrogation de la réforme du
baccalauréat de la réforme du lycée et
de parcoursup et le retour à un
baccalauréat national ponctuel terminal
anonyme et disciplinaire
de même nous condamnons dans le
supérieur la mise en place de la
plateforme mon Master qui est un
parcoursup au niveau en fin de en fin de
licence enfin bien que refusé par la
totalité des organisations syndicales le
gouvernement persiste à vouloir passer
en force son pacte qui institut de
nouvelles missions tout attentatoire au
statut et délétères qui constituent une
attaque contre le statut général et la
grille de rémunération des
fonctionnaires et poursuit avec son
pendant parce qu'il y a un lien direct
le CNR et les projets locaux locaux
pardon de l'école faisons-la ensemble
l'explosion du cadre national de l'école
et donc l'égalité des droits et de
traitement de tout les écoliers de
France et de Navarre
le gouvernement prétend régler le
problème des cours non assurés
par des remplacements de courte durée
alors déjà tâchons de remplacer les
remplacements de longue durée puisqu'il
n'est pas rare d'avoir des absences très
longues qui ne sont pas remplacées faute
de poste c'est remplacements de courte
durée sont en chronophage inutile et une
applicable ce serait même pas la même
matière qui serait sollicitée
il remet même à l'ordre du jour ce que
proposait le ministre Blanquer à savoir
les surveillance des élèves par des AED
devant des vidéos de cours alors là
outre que c'est totalement inapplicable
c'est parfaitement honteux ils prévoient
contre le statut d'envoyer les
professeurs d'écoles au collège donc il
faut accepte pas demande le rejet le
retrait du pacte qui d'ailleurs est
massivement rejeté par les personnels et
nous raffirmons nos revendications pour
restaurer l'attractivité du métier
enseignant d'une augmentation de 10%
tels que l'avait promis
Emmanuel Macron et ce qui n'est
absolument pas appliqué merci
merci pour le Syndicat général de
l'Éducation nationale CFDT madame
Sandrine Duba ou madame carvarian je ne
sais pas avec laquelle des deux commence
tous interviendrons toutes les deux tout
d'abord pour répondre à votre question
sur le report des épreuves de spécialité
en juin cela va bien sûr répondre à la
tension qui a été vécue notamment sur la
dernière session et ça répondra aussi à
la problématique de l'absentéisme de
troisième trimestre au moins en partie
mais ça va reposer la question de la
reconquête du mois de juin et ça
résoudra pas tous les problèmes liés à
l'organisation même de ce bac à la
lourdeur des programmes qui doivent être
enseignés à la nature des épreuves
elles-mêmes
de plus en lien avec cela on rappelle
que pour le zgen CFDT il faudrait
l'anonymisation anonymisation des pas
dossiers de parcoursup notamment ce qui
concerne le lycée d'origine
voilà
pour revenir à la rentrée
nous aussi osgane CFDT on fait un
constat bien moins satisfait que le
ministre beaucoup de postes n'ont pas
été pourvu par exemple dans les
Hauts-de-Seine il manquait 70 pe
professeur des écoles
mais ce ne sont pas que les professeurs
qui sont concernés par ce manque ce sont
bien tous les métiers les aesh les
adjoints gestionnaires les agents
comptables les personnels administratifs
que ce soit en EPL e ou alors dans les
services déconcentrés les services
déconcentrés qui souffrent et ceux qui
se retentit beaucoup aussi sur les
conditions de travail des personnels sur
la rémunération de certains personnels
et puis il y a aussi les personnels
médico-sociaux alors grand manque de
personnels médico-sociaux nous on
voulait vous citer un exemple le cas des
infirmières scolaires dans le
département des Deux-Sèvres département
des Deux-Sèvres c'est pas un des
départements les plus en difficulté dans
notre pays à la rentrée il y avait pour
les infirmières scolaires dans ce
département 4 postes vacants on pourrait
dire quatre postes vacants l'infirmière
pourquoi pas c'est pas très grave mais
quatre postes vacants d'infirmière ça
fait que son concernés quatre collèges
de lycée si on fait le compte on est
dans les Deux-Sèvres c'est pas les plus
gros collages de France qui sont
concernés ça nous fait à peu près 800
collégiens et 500 collégiens
qui n'avait pas d'infirmière scolaires à
la rentrée et alors là je pourrai pas
vous faire le nombre d'élèves concernés
mais les infirmières scolaires qui sont
basés en collège elles travaillent aussi
sur les écoles de leur secteur donc il y
a une vingtaine d'écoles concernées par
ce manque de 4 infirmières scolaire
alors on pourrait aussi ajouter que deux
infirmières à mi-temps ne sont pas non
plus complétés donc ça fait à peu près
autant d'écoles encore qui sont pas qui
ne sont pas couvertes par une infirmière
donc le manque de personnel il écrit en
et c'est un des gros problèmes qui du
font enfin qui qui crée beaucoup de
mauvais fonctionnement de
dysfonctionnement ensuite les
difficultés de la rentrée
au delà des chiffres et des personnes ce
sont aussi des difficultés liées au
manque de sens et au manque de
considération il y a beaucoup d'annonces
qui sont destinées au grand public mais
qui pour les personnels font l'effet
d'injonction qui sont difficilement
applicables et puis sans concertation
aucune avec les personnes sur le terrain
les collègues se demandent
tellement de fois à la suite de ces
injonctions de ces communications
comment dans un temps aussi contraint
que celui d'une semaine de classe ils
vont pouvoir faire tout ce qui leur est
demandé il faut arrêter absolument cette
communication qui revient en pour les
personnels à demander d'ajouter sans
cesse des nouveaux contenus sans que
jamais les programmes ne soient
réévalués et en même temps on rappelle
sans cesse en tout cas on l'entend
toujours dans les médias que on ne fait
pas assez de maths on ne fait pas assez
de français donc tout sans pile et ça
fait une réalité impossible et puis
au-delà des annonces sur les
enseignements et bien il y a quelque
chose qui a profondément heurté ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais effectivement
ça a déjà été évoqué la distribution
d'un flyer offline d'un flyer aux
familles dont la première information
qui leur était donnée c'était de dire
que l'enseignant de leur enfant avait eu
un gain de 125 euros de salaire ça a été
très mal vécu par les personnels et le
sgan cfdtr rappelle qu'une réelle
revalorisation salariale qui rattrape le
pouvoir d'achat perdu ses 20 dernières
années n'a toujours pas eu lieu et on
l'attend cette revalorisation
alors pour poursuivre sur notre constat
de rentrée pour nous le ministère c'est
le ministère ne sort pas de sa logique
d'une école pilotée par l'évaluation
permanente et par ses promenades et par
ces programmes surchargés là encore ça
ne sera qu'un affichage soyons clairs
chaque affichage auprès du grand public
fenêtre des espoirs ou familles et mais
les personnels sur le terrain en
difficulté une fois de plus on rajoute
encore 30 minutes par ci par là dans un
emploi du temps journalier surchargé par
des programmes des gens en place
d'ailleurs il ne faudrait pas confondre
à l'école primaire l'activité sportive
et le sport
trois constats concernant l'adhésion
pacte puisque cela faisait partie d'une
de vos questions déjà d'une l'obligation
de passer par le pacte déstabilise le
fonctionnement de certains
établissements des choses qui
fonctionnaient ne se feront plus par
rapport au projet des collègues qui
prennent conscience de tout ce qu'il
faisait bénévolement jusque là et qui
est nécessaire à leurs élèves pourquoi
ne serait-il pas payer alors que par
ailleurs il y a de l'argent pour de
nouvelles missions
résultat beaucoup renoncent dans
certains établissements les discussions
autour du pack génèrent ou ravive des
tensions sources de mal-être au travail
et quand on remonte et statistiques il
nous semble que c'est au ministère de
les faire
nous attendons concrètement que le pôle
médico-social soit réellement renforcé
pour une meilleure prise en charge de
l'orientation et prise en charge et de
l'orientation des élèves et de leur
famille ce pôle est aussi un maillon
essentiel pour le bien-être de l'école
et la lutte contre le harcèlement c'est
seulement avec des équipes plus
réprofessionnelles complètes que des
solutions peuvent être trouvées elles
sont par ailleurs aussi fondamentales
pour une école inclusive réussie un plan
de soutien à l'investissement pour
l'amélioration du bâti scolaire
notamment en lien avec l'amélioration de
la qualité de l'air et l'adaptation du
règlement climatique du dérèglement
climatique c'est ce que nous attendons
également
enfin une organisation de l'école qui
aujourd'hui en cette rentrée en cette
nouvelle rentrée laisse peu de place aux
acteurs de terrain un employeur qui ne
reconnaît pas sa juste mesure le travail
de ces personnel et qui ferment souvent
les yeux face au développement de la
souffrance au travail c'est ce que nous
vivons quels moyens les personnels
ont-ils alors pour offrir un cadre
serein et propice au bien-être facteurs
essentiels de la réussite des
apprentissages des élèves
merci merci pour la CGT éducation
poursuivra bon on va pas on va du coup
on va pouvoir économiser un peu de temps
parce que on est bien sûr d'accord avec
beaucoup de choses qui ont été
précédemment dites alors nous vous les
soulignez une rentrée scolaire
catastrophique en Guyane et en Mayotte
c'est vraiment des délaissés de la
République
et vraiment c'est c'est inadmissible
qu'on puisse laisser des familles des
élèves et des enseignants dans ces
situations dramatiques alors dans le
premier degré ça a été déjà été dit la
question de la carte scolaire et bien on
dès le mois de juin on n'écoute pas les
ce que rapporte les organisations
syndicales ce que rapporte les
directeurs et les directrices d'écoles
les dazen procèdent à des fermetures
j'allais dire de manière tout à fait
idéologique et puis à la rentrée on
réouvre par ci par là mais en fait ce
qui se passe c'est qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de réajustements à la rentrée
qui désorganise complètement les équipes
et qui d'ailleurs pose aussi des soucis
au personnel administratifs qui doivent
gérer cette gestion j'allais dire la
petite semaine puisque non seulement il
y a des titulaires mais en plus à gérer
toute la masse de contractuel qui est
maintenant généralisée dans tous les
départements dans le premier degré les
temps partiel ça a été dit ça pose un
vrai problème parce que les temps
partiels ne sont pas sont accordés ou
pas d'ailleurs mais quand ils sont
accordés il n'y a pas de complément de
service il s'est trouvé ici même à Paris
plusieurs collègues qui étaient à temps
partiels et qui ont assuré j'allais dire
un temps complet alors qu'on ils étaient
à temps partiel parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de complément de service c'était
pareil pour des décharges de direction
des décharges syndicales c'est la
question du recrutement donc massif
maintenant des contractuels dans de dans
le premier degré je donne quelques
exemples dans le 77 pas très loin d'ici
c'est 423 contractuels c'est le double
de l'année dernière
dans le 94 c'est 408 contractuelles dans
le 13 dans les Bouches-du-Rhône c'est
160 contrat actuels voilà dans le Zap
maritimes ça représente maintenant 3% de
la masse des professeurs des écoles en
comptant les contractuels donc ça
commence à devenir extrêmement sérieux
et ça prouve bien qu'il y a un vrai
déficit de recrutement oui parce qu'il y
a aussi effectivement un problème
d'attractivité comme dit mes collègues
et puis il y a des inégalités sur les
territoires parce que Ben avec les
restrictions budgétaires il y a beaucoup
de communes qui ont réduit leur budget
dans les écoles un fort de France c'est
11 euros par élève et puis il y a
d'autres endroits c'est 50 euros mais en
tout cas il y a des vrais inégalités qui
sont en train de se développer et puis
je
développerai juste un tout petit point
sur les collants complètement ce qui a
été dit par ma collègue de l'UNSA c'est
à dire qu'on est en train d'amalgamer la
question du handicap et de la grande
difficulté scolaire et si on met pas et
si on fait pas un vrai choix politique
mais un vrai choix politique de
constituer les raz de reformer des
enseignants spécialisés des maîtres eux
des maîtres g la Dazaine de mon
département nous a même dit j'allais
dire d'une manière désespérance et ça si
vous connaissez des personnes qui ont le
diplôme le DEES de psychologie on prend
même retraités alors on va éviter
d'embaucher des personnes qui ont 85 ans
mais voilà où on en est donc c'est c'est
très très grave ce qui est en train de
se passer sur la question de l'école
inclusives et voilà je vais pas répéter
ce qui a été dit par ma collègue parce
que on rejoint complètement ce qui a été
dit voilà je vous remercie
il n'y avait pas un enseignant devant
chaque classe et dans les collèges et
les lycées nous en fait le constat de
des multiples postes vacants et
aujourd'hui encore de nombreux postes ne
sont pas pourvus sur le et les côtes on
les connaît depuis longtemps il y a une
dégradation des conditions salariales un
décalage entre la l'inflation et les
faibles hausse du point d'indice si là
on est sur une perte en deux ans une
perte de salaire réelle de 5,5%, qui a
accentuent les pertes de pouvoir d'achat
à successives de plus de 16% depuis 2010
et le pacte t'inventer ce n'est pas une
revalorisation c'est un alourdissement
de la charge de la charge de travail
pour des personnels qui selon la dette
le service statistique du ministère
travaille déjà en moyenne 43 heures
semaine sur les effets concrets du pacte
on assiste à une dégradation des emplois
du temps et il va y avoir aussi une
aggravation des inégalités Finlande
dans dans certaines académies pendant
les réunions de prérentrée il y a eu
l'annonce que les formations que la
formation continue serait maintenant
systématiquement
en dehors du temps des vacances
scolaires et de donc ce qu'il a encore
va poser des questions des inégalités
famom et va dégrader l'attractivité du
métier avec encore une une
alourdissement de la charge de travail
le donc on a dit pas un enseignant dans
chaque classe mais aussi de grosses
difficultés sur tous les postes non ce
qu'on dit non enseignants la médecine
scolaire est sinistrée il y a un manque
de personnel sociaux et médecine
scolaire et personnel sociaux manquent
particulièrement dans les endroits où
les élèves sont les plus fragiles on a
rarement vu autant d'annonces sur les
réseaux sociaux pour des recrutement d
sur le
sur le report des épreuves du bac en
juin dans les lycées généraux
technologiques donc on peut prendre acte
après quatre ans d’aler de la part des
organisations syndicales le calendrier
du bac est enfin adapté mais on peut que
déplorer le fait que ça c'est toujours
une hypothèse qui existe dans le projet
de réforme de la voie professionnelle
projet présenté comme un projet de lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire qu'on voit
les conséquences qu'il y avait eu le les
épreuves anticipées en LGT c'est
vraiment
ubuesque et cette aménagement de l'année
terminale en bac pro avec des épreuves
anticipées anticipé donc c'est une
nouvelle baisse de temps de formation
professionnelle générale pour les élèves
mais avec la gratification des stages
qui est annoncée
le choix entre les deux parcours plus de
stage d'entreprise ou préparation de des
poursuites d'études risque de dissuader
les élèves de s'engager vers des
poursuites d'études donc cette mise en
place qui a commencé à essayer de
rentrer d'une nouvelle réforme de la
voie professionnelle ça génère beaucoup
d'inquiétudes chez les PLP on a dit une
perte de sens du métier
l'annonce de la fermeture de 100% des
formations menant insuffisamment à
l'emploi et à la poursuite d'études
visant particulièrement les filières
tertiaires très féminisées dans les ça
inquiète fortement les collègues et dans
les fêtes ne pas tenir compte des envies
des élèves et piloter uniquement avec
les taux d'insertion de l'emploi c'est
produire plus d'orientation subie pour
les élèves et donc mécaniquement plus de
décrochage
et on voit déjà dans certains
départements qu'on peut anticiper
notamment le miennes ou les formatures
les fermetures de formation en
tertiaires ont été anticipées ça fait
deux années que des centaines d'élèves
restent
jusqu'au vers la dernière je commande
les élèves de moins de 16 ans sont en
place en sans affectation au lycée et
les fermetures de formation tertiaires
ont été une des causes et la Défenseur
des droits a obtenu le chiffre de cette
année de 13500 lycéens et lycéens sans
affectation donc 13000 jeunes de moins
de 16 ans qui n'ont pas de place en
lycée
et dernière point dernier point sur la
rentrée on l'a vu les événements
climatiques extrêmes deviennent de plus
en plus fréquents il y a eu aucune aucun
aménagement pendant les périodes de
fortes chaleurs de la rentrée et trop
d'établissements qui sont des passeports
thermiques en hiver sur des bouilloires
thermiques dans les périodes de canicule
et simple exemple la semaine de la
rentrée des collègues dans un lycée
polyvalent des Yvelines on fait le
constat qui il faisait 45 degrés dans la
dans les ateliers
merci pour le snalk je ne ce sera moi
mesdames et messieurs les députés
bonjour pour le snack que je vais
insister déjà sur deux points qui nous
semblent absolument incontournable et
absolument
urgent et qui sont deux points sur
lesquels la représentation nationale que
vous incarnez pourrait tout à fait
influer le premier point c'est la crise
des recrutements plus de 3000 postes non
pourvu cette année plus de 4000 postes
l'an dernier ce sont les deux pires
années qu'on ait jamais connues
probablement en termes de recrutement de
postes non pourvu d'enseignants cette
crise des recrutement elle repose sur
plusieurs facteurs mais le facteur
premier comme nous l'indique nos
enquêtes internes c'est le facteur de la
rémunération
les enseignants dans ce pays sont mal
payés j'ose espérer que maintenant cela
fait consensus
que puisque nous avons absolument tous
les chiffres pour le prouver que ce soit
en comparaison internationale ou que ce
soit simplement en comparant la
rémunération des fonctionnaires de
catégories A dans la fonction publique
d'État alors même que les enseignants
ont un concours à bac + 5 actuellement
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à faire
certaines années démesurées et d'autres
années rien
au-delà du contexte inflationniste qui
de toute façon a complètement dévoré la
mesure
socle qui avait été annoncé en grande
pompe et qui s'est soldé je le rappelle
pour plus des deux tiers des enseignants
par une hausse de 95 euros par mois
voilà c'est ça la grande revalorisation
des enseignants c'est 95 euros par mois
92 dans le second degré il faut
absolument offrir des perspectives pour
donner aux étudiants notamment l'envie
de rejoindre notre métier nous demandons
au snack et nous le demandons avec
encore plus de force que l'an dernier
une loi de programmation pluriannuelle
pour définir
sur cinq ans sur 10 ans on peut tout 16
discute mais pour définir une
augmentation salariale pour donner des
perspectives on ne peut pas chaque année
se battre des mois et des mois avec le
budget de l'année sans savoir de quoi
l'année prochaine sera faite nous
demandons évidemment l'arrêt des
suppressions de postes je reviens pas
sur les chiffres mais les tailles des
classes sont aujourd'hui invivables les
séries technologiques à 35 dans les
lycées généraux et technologiques par
exemple ce n'est pas possible de faire
un enseignement correct nous alertons
sur ce qui est en train de se passer sur
la formation continue qui effectivement
est en train d'être mise hors du temps
devant élève contrairement d'ailleurs à
ce qui est normalement prévu dans la
fonction publique où elle est supposer
avoir lieu sur le temps de service pour
tous les fonctionnaires la formation
continue des enseignants viendrait donc
en plus de l'ensemble du travail qu'ils
font déjà et constitueraient ainsi une
augmentation objective de leur temps de
travail de leur charge de travail et une
dégradation objective du coup
de leurs conditions de travail un point
sur le pacte qui a été perçu comme
une quelque chose de choquant au vu de
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
nous serions dans une situation où le
métier d'enseignant attirerait tout le
monde se battrait pour passer des
concours il pourrait peut-être y avoir
des discussions sur on vous donne des
missions supplémentaires contre
rémunération nous sommes dans un métier
en grave crise comment ose-t-on proposer
une revalorisation fondée en partie sur
du travail plus pour gagner plus alors
qu'on n'arrive pas à recruter
aujourd'hui c'est véritablement quelque
chose de fou et le snack demande que les
enveloppes budgétaires du pacte soit
reversés sur une part inconditionnelle
de rattrapage salarial le deuxième point
sur lequel je veux attirer votre
attention Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés c'est celui de l'école inclusive
dont on vous a annoncé l'acte 2 le snalk
signal que la politique de l'école
inclusive qui est portée à bout de bras
par les personnels de l'Éducation
nationale les enseignants les vies
scolaires les directions et évidemment
les accompagnants d'élèves en situation
de handicap qui sont dans des situations
de précarité absolument honteuse
honteuse
cette politique s'est faite depuis le
début sans jamais nous consulter sans
jamais regarder les effets qu'elle a
dans nos écoles dans nos collèges et
dans nos lycées la souffrance qu'elle
provoque aussi bien chez l'élève inclus
dans de nombreux cas chez les autres
élèves j'ai les personnels chez les
familles qui à qui on a vendu un mirage
à qui on a dit que leur enfant serait
merveilleusement accompagné et qui se
rendent compte que c'est une absolue
imposture nous ne pouvons pas continuer
ainsi nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
faire une politique d'inclusion sans
réfléchir
à ses conséquences sur l'école bien
entendu tout le monde et pour que l'on
apporte tout ce qu'il faut à l'ensemble
des enfants en situation de handicap
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous ne le faisons pas nous
avons une politique quantitative qui
gère des morceaux d'aesh pour les placer
sur des morceaux d'élèves dans des
morceaux de cours peu importe
l'intérêt pédagogique derrière peu
importe si c'est adapté ou non ou
handicap de l'enfant
le snalk demande donc qu'avant que nous
lançons un acte 2 nous fassions
collectivement avec les organisations
syndicales représentatives des
personnels le bilan de l'acte 1 car au
vu de l'acte 1 la pièce de théâtre que
nous sommes en train de fabriquer est
une tragédie
quelques points dans les minuscules
secondes qui me restent rappeler un
point sur la direction d'école il y a
certes une loi cette loi n'a pas aidé en
termes d'accompagnement humain les
directrices et directeurs d'école qui
sont toujours autant surchargés de
travail cela ne peut plus continuer sur
le baccalauréat j'avais retenu et le
snack demande toujours des examens
fondés sur des épreuves terminales
nationales et anonymes nous nous
réjouissons du retour des épreuves de
spécialité en juin cela n'épuise pas le
sujet de la réforme du bac qui a encore
beaucoup de choses qui ne vont pas
l'inclusion du grand oral dans
l'ensemble qui pose beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes le passage de trois
spécialités en première à deux
spécialités en terminale par exemple je
vous alerte aussi sur la réforme du
collège dont personne ne comprend où
elle va actuellement mis à part à
supprimer la technologie en classe de 6e
ce qui était une folie furieuse
sur la réforme de la voix
professionnelle dont personne non plus
ne comprend à peu près où elle va et
enfin
le snipe s'inquiète des derniers propos
tenus sur le service national universel
il rappelle que ce n'est pas à l'école
d'assurer le service après-vente du s&u
si le gouvernement veut faire le SNU il
peut le faire Hortense scolaire mais
certainement pas en lieu et place des
heures de cours dans nos élèves ont
besoin je vous remercie
merci pour la fédération SUD éducation
madame Maud vallejas bonjour à toutes et
tous donc pour parler de la rentrée pour
celui d'éducation il faut commencer par
parler de la principale cause d'asphyxie
de l'école des collèges et des lycées et
vous aurez compris en entendant mais mes
collègues qu'il s'agit bien de la
question des postes le manque de
personnel est criant dans l'éducation
nationale en cette rentrée encore dans
le premier degré le manque de remplaçant
de remplaçante et de AZ conduit les
personnels à une grande solitude les
refus de temps partiels sont très mal
vécus par les personnels pour beaucoup
d'entre eux et elles c'est temps partiel
sur autorisation c'est une manière de
pouvoir continuer à faire leur travail
et là on a on les refusant sur la
rentrée on les a mis dans des situations
de grande difficulté dans le second
degré de la même façon le manque de
remplaçant et de remplaçante et criant
il y a trop d'élèves par classe surtout
en lycée on a beaucoup d'établissements
qui sont mobilisés de la rentrée sur la
question des effectifs avec des classes
parfois à Karen 36 y compris en lycée
professionnel
donc une rentrée comme ça on peut on
sait que pour les personnels ça veut
dire une année extrêmement difficile et
pour les élèves également un manque fort
de personnel médico-sociaux là encore il
y a des établissements qui sont
mobilisés c'est pas possible d'avoir et
surtout dans des établissements qui
relèvent de l'éducation prioritaire ou
de la politique de la ville des rentrées
qui se font sans personnel
médico-sociaux sociaux sans infirmière
sans assistance de service social et
cela à l'absence de ces personnels à la
rentrée et particulièrement dommageables
parce que c'est le moment où les
familles vont faire leur dossier de
bourse ça c'est un élément qui est très
important et qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est aussi l'accès pour les familles
à la science sociale c'est l'accès pour
les élèves à la santé et on peut pas on
peut pas négliger ça né un manque
d'avressage qui est criant quand les
pial ont été mis en place on nous avait
dit ne vous inquiétez pas à la
mutualisation ça sera trois quatre
élèves maximum par collègue aesh non
trouvé que c'était déjà beaucoup trop
pour assurer un pont suivi aujourd'hui
dans les établissements scolaires les
avsa sont des emplois du temps avec 10
élèves 11 élèves suivis comment est-ce
qu'on peut correctement accompagner un
élève en situation de handicap alors que
on va d'un élève à l'autre d'une heure à
l'autre en passant d'un handicap à
l'autre sans formation
également un manque de CPE d'AED quand
on parle de harcèlement scolaire et
quand l'actualité est aussi tragique que
celle que l'on connaît c'est absolument
dramatique de voir que les personnels
qui accompagnent les élèves dans leur
scolarité sont au nombre insuffisants
pour faire leur travail correctement
mais également un manque de
documentaliste quand on parle par
exemple et encore une fois de
cyber-harcèlement d'éducation aux médias
aux réseaux sociaux on remarque que
l'absence de ces personnels et est
terrible
comment recruter davantage c'est la
question qui se pose d'abord en
augmentant les salaires parce que le
socle n'est pas une revalorisation c'est
des mesures qui ont limité les effets de
l'inflation il faut le dire il faut le
répéter c'est comme ça que le vive les
collègues 95 euros par mois ce n'est pas
une revalorisation dans un contexte
d'inflation il faut également cesser
d'augmenter sans cesse le temps de
travail des personnels qui est déjà très
important le pacte et le remplacement de
courte durée
voilà on peut on peut on peut voir à dès
la rentrée que c'est plutôt un échec
puisque les personnels n'ont pas signé
le pacte ils y sont même plutôt
allergiques mais en tout cas ces mesures
de pacte et de RCD comme les annonces
sur la formation continue hors temps de
service sont une vraie insulte aux
conditions de travail des personnels qui
ne peuvent pas assurer en plus de leur
mission d'enseignement qui sont déjà
dans des conditions difficiles en raison
de la du trop grand nombre d'élèves par
classe comme on l'a dit à tout à l'heure
compliqué il va falloir revenir là
dessus il va falloir travailler sur la
formation des personnels puisque nous
nous sommes tout à fait favorables à ce
que les personnes soient formées mais
sur ton service et c'est même nécessaire
pour répondre aux enjeux de l'école
aujourd'hui aux enjeux
environnementaux aux enjeux sur le
harcèlement aux enjeux sur le handicap
sur la rentrée scolaire encore les
personnels ont été marqués en cette
rentrée par l'interdiction des abeilles
à la rentrée 2023 que Sud-Education a
dénoncé cette interdiction stigmatise
des vêtements portés par les jeunes
filles musulmanes ou supposés en voulant
contrôler leur corps à quelques jours de
la reprise on a pris cette annonce comme
l'idée que certaines élèves les élèves
musulmanes un ne serait perçu comme pas
bienvenue à l'école
cette interdiction s'ajoute au texte qui
a été publié pendant l'été au sujet du
harcèlement scolaire qui permettra au
chef d'établissement de saisir des
conseils de discipline pour des
atteintes aux principes de laïcité on a
donc des jeunes filles qui pourront se
retrouver en conseil de discipline et
même définitivement exclu de leur
établissement parce qu'elles ne
porteront pas une robe de la bonne
longueur les dérives sont à craindre en
cette rentrée scolaire on refuse de
mettre sur le même plan des faits
pénalement répréhensibles le
cyber-harcèlement par exemple et les
tenues des lycéennes
si la République doit faire bloc pour
reprendre les propos du ministre c'est
pour défendre l'école publique et la
publication des IPS l'année dernière a
montré que l'enseignement privé est
responsable du manque de mixité sociale
lorsqu'un collège favorisé est situé
près d'un établissement des favorisé
dans 85% des cas c'est un établissement
privé ainsi la présence de
l'établissement privé nuit à la mixité
sociale à leur même que le privé est
financé à 73% par l'État donc si la
République doit faire bloc encore c'est
contre les inégalités sociales
qu'aggravent l'école dans notre pays
l'éducation prioritaire a été mise à sac
depuis 10 ans il serait temps de
reprendre une vraie politique
d'éducation prioritaire avec un
abondement de moyens et le retour des
lycées dans l'éducation prioritaire
ensuite je voudrais développer la
question des conditions de travail des
personnels aesh et de l'école inclusive
les annonces de la Conférence nationale
du handicap ne vont pas du tout dans le
bon sens pour nous l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui maltraitante avec les élèves
en situation de handicap les pial la
mutualisation ont morcelé
l'accompagnement comme je disais tout à
l'heure de on a des ash qui accompagnent
parfois 10 élèves les ash les élèves
sont accompagnés par plusieurs ash en
plus il y a pas de vrais suivi pas de
vraies formations et beaucoup de
maltraitance à la fois pour les
personnels et pour les élèves nous
revendique un vrai statut de la fonction
publique pour les aesh et je voudrais
ici rappeler que les aesh sont en très
grande majorité des femmes maintenir 130
000 femmes dans la précarité comme le
fait l'éducation nationale c'est-à-dire
avec des femmes qui n'ont pas les moyens
de se nourrir quotidiennement qui
doivent sauter des repas c'est la
situation de nos collègues par exemple
qu'il me dit ne mange pas parce qu'elles
n'ont pas les moyens
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
inacceptable pour nous il faut agir et
quand on parle d'inégalité homme-femme
et d'inégalité salariale cette question
là elle est absolument centrale pour
nous donc on revendique un temps de
travail de 24 heures pour les aesh
puisqu'on estime que l'accompagnement le
travail de concertation avec les équipes
et un travail à part entière et enfin je
voudrais terminer sur la question de la
canicule puisque c'est aussi ça qui a
marqué la rentrée des des élèves et des
personnels puisqu'on a mesuré des
températures allant jusqu'à 35 degrés
dans les salles de classe en même temps
on avait des annonces gouvernementales
sur le fond vert de 500 millions d'euros
quand on voit les prévisions de ce qui
serait nécessaire de faite par l'ADEME
par exemple ou le rapport de Marc qui
nous disent qu'il ne faudra a priori 40
milliards à 50 milliards pour rénover le
bâti scolaire on se demande ce qu'on va
faire avec 500 millions si ce n'est
mettre des volets aux écoles c'est
insuffisant il faut absolument en cette
rentrée penser à la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments ça veut dire rénover des
amiés
tétoniser les cours d'école améliorer la
gestion des déchets c'est une nécessité
quand on parle des conditions de travail
des élèves et des personnels il faudra
aussi réfléchir à la question des
températures minimum et maximum dans les
classes et à l'aménagement des horaires
de classe si nécessaire enfin nous
tenions alerter sur la situation de
Mayotte où le manque d'eau est
absolument indigne pour notre pays il y
a une urgence à agir et nous souhaitions
vous alerter sur ce sujet puisque les
mesures nécessaires de distribution
d'eau en quantité c'est suffisante
doivent être déployés pour garantir des
conditions sanitaires décentes il y va
de la sécurité et de la santé de nos
élèves de nos personnels et des
habitants et des habitants de Mayotte je
vous remercie
merci et je remercie vraiment tous les
participants d'avoir bien je voulais
jouer le jeu de la contrainte du temps
et je vais demander la même chose à mes
collègues donc pour des interventions de
2 minutes et nous allons commencer par
Renaissance avec Véronique criotton
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs mes chers collègues alors
quelques fois le temps caricatural que
vous utilisez Nonore pas le corps
professoral que vous êtes censé
représenter et en fait vous parlez du
manque évidemment de poste et puis la
difficulté des salaires insuffisants or
vous gagnerez à reconnaître lorsque nous
faisons avancer les sujets dès 2017 nous
avons agi pour offrir à notre pays
l'instruction qu'il mérite je rappelle
c'est 13% de plus de budget en 5 ans
vous pourriez l'honorer c'est de la
revalorisation des salaires pour près de
1,1 milliard d'euros avec une
mobilisation très forte pour cette année
particulièrement des pour pouvoir les
postes et la lutte contre le harcèlement
vous en avez parlé harcèlement scolaire
et évidemment le prosélytisme et
l'entrisme religieux c'est une réponse
qui est directe à une demande des
établissements qui nous ont été faits
notamment sur la question de la Baya et
en tout cas pour clarifier les choses et
c'est souvent intéressant de voir la
rhétorique que vous avez sur ce sujet là
nous nous attendons à tous les sujets
parce que l'éducation nationale et ceux
qui y travaillent le mérite est-ce que
vous êtes des organisations
représentatives des enseignants certains
vont jusqu'à refuser de dire qu'il signe
le pacte par les pressions que vous
faites c'est inacceptable sur la façon
dont vous fonctionnez donc des
établissements les établissements
indiquent des des enseignants qui ne
refusent de dire ce que vous faites
absolument et donc je suis profondément
respectueuse du corps enseignant et la
vocation qui les anime en tout cas du
corps enseignant moi j'aimerais dire que
sur le pacte par exemple j'ai un papa
qui est psychologue scolaire et qui
aurait aimé en son temps signé pour
pouvoir travailler plus et gagner plus
pour améliorer le pouvoir d'achat donc
en tout cas ce pacte il apporte
évidemment une vraie amélioration et
répond aux besoins et nous avons besoin
d'avoir merci une représentation
collègues j'ai demandé aux organisations
syndicales une exemplaire a été donc je
vous la demande aussi au rassemblement
national Julien Audoux merci
merci Madame le Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues je pense que nous gagnerions à
nous écouter autrement ça va être juste
un brouha et les organisations
syndicales n'entendront pas ce que les
députés et les uns les autres ont à dire
donc voilà je suis garante du de la
bonne tenue des débats que chacun puisse
s'écouter donc la parole est au
rassemblement national et à Julien
Oudoul merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les représentants des
syndicats d'enseignants nous avons
écouté
religieusement alors même que certains
de vous propose étaient choquants et que
d'autres propos pouvaient s'apparenter
au sketch des Inconnus sur la grève du
lycée donc très clairement si les
parlementaires pouvaient être entendus
pouvez poser une question sans être
justement interrompu moi j'aimerais vous
interroger sur deux phénomènes qui ont
été rapidement évoqués qui ont marqué
cette rentrée scolaire c'est d'abord les
conséquences du harcèlement le
harcèlement scolaire qui est identifié
depuis de trop nombreuses années qui a
vu le petit Nicolas donc 15 ans se
suicider à Poissy donc en cette rentrée
qui touche des centaines de milliers
voire un million d'élèves selon un
rapport du Sénat et qui est
véritablement un fléau qui est toujours
évoqué mais qui n'a jamais été
malheureusement
contenu le deuxième phénomène qui va
choquer certainement les plus
islamo-gauchistes d'entre vous c'est
évidemment l'interdiction de la Baya de
la tenue islamiste appelée abaya à la
suite d'une part de la mobilisation du
rassemblement national à la suite aussi
de nombreux sondages je rappelle celui
d'août dernier ou 75% des Français se
prononcent en faveur de l'interdiction
de la Baya et contre l'entrisme
islamiste on voit bien que la mesure qui
a été prise la circulaire par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale ne va
pas endiguer les intrusions islamistes
donc moi ma question était très simple à
partir de ces deux phénomènes qui sont
des vrais réalités et qui posent un défi
à l'école de la République est-ce que
pour vous la solution en tout cas l'une
des solutions pour être l'instauration
d'une tenue unique dans les
établissements scolaires tels qu'elle a
été proposée par mon collègue Roger judo
sous la forme d'une proposition loi
telle qu'elle pour être expérimenté
comme le souhaite le gouvernement quelle
est votre avis maintenant pour aider
fille Léo Walter j'ai je coupe à deux
minutes à tout le monde merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues je tiens
d'abord à saluer la tenue de cette table
ronde avec les organisations syndicales
c'était une demande de mon groupe
l'année dernière portée au bureau de
notre commission par ma collègue Sarah
Legrand et je me félicite qu'elle était
maintenu pour cette année le tour
d'horizon que vous nous avez présenté
contre dit nettement l'affirmation du
dgsco que nous auditionnions ce matin
selon lui je cite techniquement cette
rentrée scolaire s'est bien passée or il
me semble que la seule chose dont on
puisse se réjouir c'est que l'école
publique ait été au centre de toutes les
attentions malheureusement pour de bien
mauvaises raisons on vient de le voir
échec prévisible du choc d'attractivité
et du pacte enseignant poste non pourvu
m'en criant de personnels de vie
scolaire ou médico-social daesh
harcèlement scolaire les sujets
d'inquiétude vous l'avez dit sont
nombreux mes collègues il reviendront
dans leurs interventions je souhaitais
quant à moi vous interroger sur trois
points en particulier le premier
concerne les élèves 80 000 enfants mal
logés en France dans la moitié non
scolarisé plus de 2000 d'entre eux
dorment la rue un chiffre en
augmentation de 20%, le coût des
fournitures explose ainsi que les
factures d'alimentation ou d'énergie or
toute fragilisation des familles tout
augmentation de la précarité se
répercutent sur les élèves et leurs
apprentissages l'école est en première
ligne de votre point de vue est-elle en
mesure de faire face le second point
concerne les enseignants et en
particulier les enseignants débutants
récent article de Libération mettant
lumière un secret de polichinelle le
caractère parfois mortifère de la
formation et de l'accompagnement des
débuts de carrière harcèlement dossier à
charge intimidation provoquant des
arrêts maladie voire des démissions
précoces c'est un tableau bien noir de
l'année de stage que révèle les
témoignages recueillis une enquête menée
pour la revue des sciences humaines en
2020 auprès de 5530 stagiaires pointez
déjà leur souffrance au travail entre
injonction paradoxale charge de travail
démesurée et sentiment d'impuissance à
votre avis quelles actions résolue
pourrait mener l'institution pour
remédier à ce triste état de fait enfin
j'ai Inter ce matin sur l'écart entre le
salaire net des enseignants et celui des
autres cadres A de la fonction publique
d'État presque 1000 euros de moins selon
l'Insee je n'ai pas eu de réponse quels
sont les revendications de vos
organisations sur le sujet je vous
remercie de votre écoute et de vos
réponses monsieur le député pour les
républicains Alexandre portier merci
Madame la présente mesdames messieurs
merci pour vos interventions riches et
animées tous ceux qui aiment l'école
reconnaîtront non sans difficulté que il
y a un point évidemment aujourd'hui où
nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur en
France évidemment la question des
rémunérations du monde du monde scolaire
et le choc qu'on attendait n'est pas au
rendez-vous il faut admettre qu'on est
très loin de ce qui serait nécessaire
pour avoir aujourd'hui une attractivité
et refaire des enseignants un corps
d'excellence de la fonction publique on
est toujours très loin des bons élèves
de l'Union européenne très loin de nos
voisins allemands et une large partie
des rémunérations qui sont proposées le
sont sous forme de prime ce qui n'est
pas acceptable puisqu'elle n'entre pas
en compte pour la retraite ce n'est
juste inacceptable je vous reconnais ce
point pour le reste j'aurai des
interrogations et j'aimerais vous
entendre sur deux points en particulier
notamment la question de la part des
contractuels on a de plus en plus du
contrat actuel dans l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui 10 moyenne 10% en
moyenne aujourd'hui en France on recrute
par speed dating par petites annonce a
été évoqué ce qui entraîne des
conditions dumping absolument
déplorables et qui sont en
catastrophique à long terme pour l'école
et pour le pays on a un événement par le
bas qui est extrêmement inquiétant
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous proposez
concrètement pour améliorer le
recrutement des enseignants et puis le
deuxième point d'interrogation porte sur
ce à quoi on a assisté à la rentrée avec
une volonté de reprise en main de
l'éducation nationale de l'école par le
Président de la République je pense
notamment à l'interview au point mais
pas que avec des annonces tous azimut
dont on peine souvent à comprendre la
cohérence j'aimerais comprendre comment
vous analysez cette reprise en main
est-ce qu'elle signifie une bonne
nouvelle est-ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle de voir le président annoncé
que c'est un domaine réservé ou est-ce
que pour vous c'est autre chose et
notamment une immense escroquerie je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
pour les démocrates Géraldine Bannier
mesdames Messieurs Je m'écœure jour
après jour après avoir passé 16 ans mon
éclat de collège et lycée à transmettre
aussi bien que possible en névalise de
mots que l'on vit de mieux écrire mieux
parler la rigueur positive et
transposable ailleurs des six belles
langues anciennes d'abord que ce sujet
de la transmission soit si peu évoqué
dans le milieu politique où je navigue à
présent et ensuite d'entendre
quotidiennement des horreurs sur les
professeurs trop de vacances des pauses
café alors qu'il y a le harcèlement des
professeurs qui doivent être formés
comme s'ils ignoraient la société qui
les entourent le sujet laïcité l'urgence
environnementale la vie des entreprises
ah comme il est trop fermé ce monde
entendons régulièrement c'est
décourageants quand on enseigne car la
tâche est dure des groupes de 25 à 35 3
à 4 heures par jour une attention à
chacun qui nous poursuit bien évidemment
à la maison des copies chaque week-end
ou presque et ses soupçons permanents
j'ai l'impression qu'on est à côté de la
plaque et du sujet quand j'entends
évoquer des théories du type autonomie
des établissements évaluation des
établissements calendriers scolaires qui
paraissent bien éloignés de notre
quotidien avez-vous l'impression comme
moi que la priorité est ailleurs que
l'école se débrouille encore pas si mal
dans une société qui va mal mais qu'on a
d'abord soutien d'avoir besoin du
soutien de cette société et sur la
formation hors des heures de cours moi
je dois dire que je viens d'en
établissement où c'était régulièrement
le cas parce que le principal nous met
nos heures de formation hors des heures
de cours je trouvais ça honnêtement pas
trop déconnant à condition qu'on charge
pas trop la barque en termes de
justement de poids des formations
merci pour les socialistes à parenté il
n'y a que channise bien merci Madame la
président j'avais préparé une
intervention mais je vais parler un
petit peu sans filtre comme notre
collègue Riotton déjà pour remercier les
enseignants et les représentants
syndicaux de d'avoir témoigné de leur
entrée et ses propos font écho aux
propos que nous avons obtenus nous-mêmes
ce matin quand lorsque nous auions
Edward Jeffrey et qui dénote qui
contraste avec les propos tenus par
Monsieur le DG SCO je tiens à dire que
je regrette l'absence écrasante des
collègues de la majorité pour venir
écouter les représentants syndicaux eux
qui étaient si nombreux à applaudir
Édouard Geffré ce matin nous sommes nous
aussi madame ma chère collègue
caricaturaux dès que nous sommes pas
d'accord avec vous mais les
représentants syndicaux étaient-ils
caricaturaux quand ils ont dénoncé la
réforme du bac sur laquelle vous
rétropez d'aller aujourd'hui était le
caricaturaux quand il disait que le
calendrier aller fracturer le suivi au
lycée le calendrier vous dit revenu
aujourd'hui donc j'aimerais bien avoir
une réponse sur ce sujet alors merci
merci d'avoir dénoncé les promesses non
tenues par Gabriel Attal et son
prédécesseurs sur un enseignant devant
chaque classe à la rentrée car
effectivement ce n'est pas le cas merci
d'avoir révélé de nouveau comme nous
l'état Casa catastrophique du pôle
médico-social dans nos établissements
qui est pourtant essentiel pour lutter
contre le harcèlement pour lutter contre
la fracture sociale et les inégalités
scolaires merci d'avoir appelé la
situation catastrophique des aesh et de
l'inclusion en France en 2023 merci de
vous mobiliser tous les jours pour le
bien-être des élèves des familles et
pour les générations à venir je finirai
par une question des échos qui me sont
revenus est-il vrai que des pressions
sont faits par les chefs d'établissement
ou par les rectorats pour la signature
du pack notamment pour pouvoir organiser
des sorties scolaires pour pouvoir faire
des devoirs
participer aux dispositifs devoir fait
contre les HSE qui sont encore
disponibles mais qui ont dit que ce
n'est pas le cas voilà en tout cas merci
merci monsieur le député pour horizon et
apparentés Béatrice Bellamy
merci Madame ma Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs je me réjouis que nous étions
l'occasion de faire collectivement le
bilan de la rentrée scolaire cela me
paraît essentiel pour nourrir les
réflexions de la représentation
nationale
enseignant n'est pas un métier tout à
fait comme les autres c'est certes un
métier de passion de transmission et de
relations humaines mais c'est surtout un
métier de responsabilité de services à
la nation de formation des futurs
citoyens citoyennes il est donc
primordial de mieux reconnaître
l'engagement des professeurs et de
rendre plus attractif un métier qui
malheureusement n'attire plus
suffisamment la crise d'évocation est un
défi auquel le gouvernement a choisi de
s'atteler depuis après des années de
procrastin procrastination c'est à
saluer je souhaite tout d'abord entendre
vos observations au sujet des
conséquences de la mastérisation au
tournant des années 2010 ensuite le
groupe Horizon est apparenté salut les
efforts budgétaires conséquent pour la
revalorisation salariale des professeurs
et personnels de l'Éducation nationale
le pacte deuxième volet de cette
revalorisation permet aux enseignants
volontaires de s'engager sur une mission
complémentaire répondant aux besoins de
l'établissement tous les pacs ne sont
évidemment pas encore signé mais d'ores
et déjà vous devez avoir des retours
concrets du terrain quels sont-ils quels
sont les freins que vous identifiez pour
la signature de ses pactes le volet
remplacement de courte durée est
efficient dans plusieurs établissements
en est-il de même pour le volet sur les
projets pédagogiques enfin quelle
différence faites-vous ou quelle
préconisations faites-vous au sujet de
l'application des pactes entre les
collèges le lycée général ou le lycée
professionnel je vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour les
écologistes Francesca passe uni
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues merci pour vos
remarques liminaires les défis de cette
rentrée sont nombreux l'un d'eux doit
cependant nous interpeller
collectivement le droit à l'éducation
cette année encore comme celle qui l'ont
précédé sera bafoué pour les élèves en
situation de handicap les personnels
enseignants et Ash sont en première
ligne et nous semble aujourd'hui en
grande souffrance face à une inclusion
sans moyens adaptée sans ambition
d'effectivité ni d'accessibilité pour
les parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap et les enfants eux-mêmes ils
n'en va pas autrement la sociologue
Sandrine Garcia dans son étude
enseignant de la vocation au
désenchantement
identifie l'inclusion sans moyens dans
les toutes premières sources de perte de
sens et de rupture professionnelle on
savait déjà que les aesh n'avait aucun
accès on avait accès à aucune
information sur les situations des
enfants qu'elles accompagnent elles
doivent tout découvrir par elle-même et
parfois dans la douleur par ailleurs en
nous remonte du terrain que les
enseignants du secondaire n'auraient
plus le droit de savoir qui sont les
enfants en situation de handicap qu'ils
accueillent dans leur classe en
inclusion ou comment il s'agirait
d'adapter leur pédagogie vis-à-vis de
ses enfants est-ce que c'est une réalité
que vous observez plus généralement
comment les personnels que vous
représentez vive le fait que l'école
soit aussi excluante les conditions dans
lesquelles elle opère aujourd'hui avec
des centaines de milliers d'enfants qui
sont soit très mal et ou très
partiellement accueillis sont tout
bonnement des scolarisés et sans
solutions enfin je souhaiterais avoir
votre sentiment sur un point précis
comment obtenir que les élèves inscrits
dans Les Ulis soit effectivement compter
dans les effectifs scolaires pour le
calcul de la dotation horaire globale au
second degré ou du nombre de classes à
ouvrir au premier et ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il faut automatiquement que les
dotations auraient globales
supplémentaires des dotations horaires
globales supplémentaires à raison du
nombre d'élèves en situation de handicap
merci merci madame la députée pour le
groupe GDR Elsa aussi
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues et Mesdames et Messieurs bon
d'abord merci de m'accueillir dans la
commission je les fréquenté pendant 5
ans au précédent mandat et j'avoue
pendant ces 5 ans ne pas en avoir
entendu de de députés accueillir de
cette matière de cette manière des
représentants de personnels donc
vraiment je suis heurté des propos qui
ont été tenus à votre rencontre je
m'excuse pour eux je devrais pas avoir à
le faire mais franchement je trouve pas
ça extrêmement choquant ensuite sur le
fait de dire que leur propos serait
caricaturaux je trouve que c'est
pratique collecte de la majorité de
venir dire que ces caricaturales quand
les effets des politiques de votre
majorité et de goûts du gouvernement
actuel et du gouvernement précédent ont
créé cette crise parce que ce sont des
choix politiques qui ont soit créé soit
aggravés un délabrement de l'école
publique des choix décidés il y avait
des éléments de communication de
Monsieur Blanquer puis de Monsieur
Ndiaye puis de Gabriel Attal expliquant
que ils étaient l'avocat des enseignants
expliquant que la rentrée elle est bien
se passer qui aurait un enseignant
devant chaque classe qui y aurait des
revalorisations
quel est le constat et quelle est la
réalité aujourd'hui la revalorisation
elle est pas arrivée les enseignants ont
été méprisés par les ministres de
l'Éducation nationale successifs
là-dessus on peut dire que Monsieur
Blancard était particulièrement brillant
pour les mépriser et donc on a tous ces
choix politiques successifs concrets une
très grande crise de l'école publique
des choix aussi politiques qui font en
sorte et bien que les élèves des
quartiers populaires que ce soit dans
les milieux urbains ou ruraux et bien
sont encore encore plus en difficulté
qu'il ne l'était avant dans l'école
publique tout ça ce sont vos choix alors
oui vos choix ils sont caricaturaux à
l'extrême mais il produisent pour
l'avenir de sérieuses carences pour
l'avenir de vos enfants c'est
inacceptable ce que vous venez de faire
devant les représentants de personnels
donc je poserai pas de questions parce
que je crois que mes collègues ont fait
le travail mais en tout cas je
souhaitais pas laisser les choses passer
de cette manière
merci maintenant les représentants
syndicaux vont pouvoir s'exprimer donc
les uns après les autres en fonction de
la même ce que nous avions fait au
départ donc je rappelle quand même
quelques quelques règles dans cette
commission c'est que chaque député est
libre de ses propos donc je pense que ça
c'est quand même très important on a pas
s'excuser pour les uns et les autres ça
me paraît quand même assez étonnant et
puis en proportion les groupes sont à
peu près représentés tous à la même de
la même façon donc il n'y a pas une
sur-représentation d'un certain groupe
par rapport à une sous-représentation
d'un autre non non mais je je le dis
parce que à un moment ça voudrait dire
ça laisse planer le fait qu'un certain
on va dire que certaines personnes se
désintéresseraient de l'école ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas donc je
tenais juste à le repréciser voilà les
les groupes sont à peu près tous
représentés entre un tiers à 50% de leur
effectif voilà donc c'est dit maintenant
vous avez la parole
merci ma belle Présidente je vais tenter
de répondre alors permettez-moi de vous
dire je pense que mes collègues pourront
lui dire aussi madame la députée que je
suis choquée des propos que vous avez
tenus envers les représentants des
personnels que nous sommes parce que oui
nous sommes les représentants des
personnels nous avons été élus lors des
élections professionnelles et nous
représentons les personnels donc par vos
propos vous méprisez les personnels que
nous représentons vous pouvez vous
cacher derrière votre discours et mettre
la tête dans le sable ça n'empêchera pas
nos propos d'être entendus parce que oui
il y a des politiques qui ont conduit à
ce que l'école est actuellement
et d'ailleurs je pense que les propos ne
lorsqu'ils sont lorsqu'ils sortent des
rapports de l'OCDE ne sont pas
caricaturaux ce sont des rapports et je
vous invite à le lire le rapport de
l'ecde qui est paru la semaine dernière
et à écouter les propos d'Éric
charbonnier spécialistes de l'éducation
à l'ecdf il dit bien évidemment que les
salaires en France sont moins importants
que dans les autres pays européens et
nettement important et que de ce point
de vue là on a des efforts à faire il
dit aussi que le nombre d'élèves par
classe sont beaucoup plus importants en
France que dans d'autres pays européens
et ça c'est important aussi pour réussir
à réduire les difficultés scolaires des
élèves à mettre en place une prévention
sur le harcèlement et à réduire la
difficulté et la grande difficulté
scolaire et accueillir nos élèves en
situation de handicap alors j'irai sur
sur certaines réponses notamment sur les
questions de l'inclusion d'élèves des
élèves en situation de handicap c'est
c'est vraiment une situation
catastrophique mais collagons on en
parlait je vais juste rappeler que par
exemple il nous manquons de place en
institut spécialisé en établissement
spécialisé je vais vous prendre deux
départements l'illive à nous il manque
entre 800 et 1000 places en
établissement spécialisé et dans le Nord
il manque 500 places donc les élèves qui
relèvent des IME des iteps ils ne sont
pas dans les instituts spécialisés ils
sont dans nos écoles est-ce qu'on a
donné plus de moyens aux écoles pour
fonctionner non on n'a pas abaissé les
effectifs par classe on n'a pas renforcé
les réseaux d'aide on n'a pas renforcé
les psychologues de l'éducation
nationale pour nous aider à faire face à
ces situations d'inclusion des élèves en
situation de handicap ce sont des
classes ou les les
classes débordent et enfin où les élèves
sont dans des situations tellement
difficiles parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'adultes autour d'eux ils ont besoin
d'une équipe pluridique professionnelle
autour d'eux pour être bien et on est
dans de la maltraitance de ces élèves là
des autres élèves et de et des
enseignants que nous sommes et vraiment
il y a quelque chose à faire sur cette
question là et ce n'est pas les
dispositions qui sont mises en place par
la
Conférence nationale du Han qui va
favoriser cette inclusion on a vraiment
un tournant à faire parce que de ce
point de vue là on est au bord de la
rupture alors vous pouvez ne pas
l'entendre et continuer de regarder
ailleurs mais c'est bien la réalité de
ce que nous vivons dans nos écoles la
question je pars reprendre toutes les
questions parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions sur la question des salaires
et notamment sur la question de la
revalorisation oui les enseignants
travaillent déjà beaucoup 43 heures en
moyenne par semaine ça ce sont des
enquêtes de l'Adeps ne sont pas les
organisations syndicales qui le disent
ce sont des enquêtes de la dette qui le
disent les enseignants travaillent
beaucoup et ils ne sont pas amenés à
travailler plus ils ne veulent pas ils
ne souhaitent pas travailler plus parce
qu'il veut déjà être reconnu pour le
travail qu'ils font et actuellement ils
ne le sont pas il y a une augmentation
des dimensions vous pouvez pas le nier
il y a une augmentation des démissions
dans l'éducation nationale pourquoi
parce que les conditions de travail ne
sont pas suffisamment réunies pour avoir
un bien-être au travail qui permette
d'abord d'avoir des conditions
d'enseignants pour nos élèves si nous
sommes là aussi si nous défendons nos
conditions de travail c'est aussi pour
que les conditions
les élèves soient des bonnes conditions
d'enseignement donc on peut on peut
effectivement avoir un discours qui nie
les choses mais la réalité est-elle que
il faut vraiment un sursaut dans ce pays
pour que l'éducation nationale puisse
fonctionner correctement je vous alerte
sur la question du budget puisque le
budget va arriver mais on doit pouvoir
bénéficier de la baisse démographie en
France actuellement pour renflouer
l'école pour permettre à des élèves
d'être moins nombreux dans les classes
pour qu'ils soient mieux accueillis pour
qu'ils puissent s'occuper de ses élèves
le rapport de l'ecde dit également une
chose très importante on fait beaucoup
de fondamentaux plus que dans les autres
pays et pourtant on lui dit on a des
injonctions systématiques pour nous dire
il faut en faire plus non il faut en
faire certainement autrement donc ça
nécessite de la formation initiale et je
répondrai d'ailleurs à cette question
sur la question des stagiaires
actuellement pourquoi les stagiaires
sont de mauvaise condition pourquoi ils
abandonnent le métier parce qu'ils sont
en situation d'enseignement en direct
avec la classe ils ont à la fois un
concours à préparer ils ont un sera
préparé et ils sont dans les classes à
travailler et il nous le disent ils sont
en situation compliquée pour pour
réussir à avoir à tenir tous les bouts
donc il faut il ne faut pas les mettre
en situation d'enseignement c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a des problèmes de
recrutement dans nos départements parce
que justement on a mis les stagiaires en
situation d'enseignement je m'arrêter là
je pense que j'ai pas répondu à tout
mais il y avait beaucoup si on veut que
si vous voulez que chacun de vos
collègues puisse répondre il est
important de pouvoir j'ai envie de dire
de faire des réponses d'environ cinq
minutes comme ça ça permettra à chacun
de parce qu'il y a une deuxième salle de
questions ensuite donc c'est pour cela
alors oui je vais en 5 minutes ça fera
10 minutes si vous faites vous nous avez
pas donné les règles du jeu
il y a encore des collègues qui doivent
poser des questions donc voilà c'est
juste histoire je vais essayer de faire
un peu moins mais c'est comme vous
voulez après si faudra passer parce qu'à
un moment enfin on va pas pouvoir rester
là jusqu'à 20h donc c'était juste pour
que chacun puis s'exprimer et avoir les
réponses qu'il souhaitaient
merci moi je voudrais commencer par une
anecdote pour vous répondre il se trouve
qu'avant d'être secrétaire général du
sncfu je suis professeur de sciences
économiques et sociales et je continue
d'enseigner puisque j'ai quatre classes
en responsabilité dans ce que je fais
une maryse de faire des sorties
scolaires alors je sais pas si je vais
pouvoir continuer à en faire beaucoup vu
que je vais pas signer le pacte mais il
se trouve que dans les sorties scolaires
que j'ai pu faire j'ai pu amener des
élèves ici à l'Assemblée nationale avec
l'idée de leur faire découvrir ce que
c'était que la démocratie et d'en faire
découvrir ce que c'est que la démocratie
et le respect
il y a le respect des institutions et le
respect des élections
et nous sommes des organisations
représentatives qui avons été élus donc
par vos propos non seulement vous
méprisez les organisations syndicales
les personnels mais aussi la démocratie
et je voudrais quand même vous alerter
là-dessus parce que dans la crise que
connaît l'éducation nationale il y a
aussi une crise très profonde qui est
liée à la perte de crédibilité dans la
parole politique et c'est ce qu'on
entend dans les salles des professeurs
c'est ce qu'on entend parce qu'on a des
collègues qui nous disent mais le
ministre nous promet ceci et ce n'est
pas ce qui arrive le ministre même pas
le ministre le candidat Emmanuel Macron
nous a promis une augmentation de 10%
sans contrepartie en janvier 2023 nous
n'avons rien eu en janvier 2023 en
septembre 2023 ça ne sera pas 10% pour
tout le monde vous évoquez les chiffres
pour faire 10% d'augmentation pour tout
le monde il faut 3 milliards 6
il n'y a pas 3 milliards 6 qui ont été
mis sur la table donc un moment cet
écart se gouffre entre la parole
politique et la réalité que nous vivons
je pourrais vous parler aussi de la
promesse d'un professeur devant chaque
classe à la rentrée il faut que vous
mesuriez l'effet que ça aussi sur la
crédibilité de la parole politique et la
façon dont on vit cette crise
démocratique et moi j'ai envie de vous
alerter solennellement aussi là dessus
parce que vous êtes les représentants
les députés l'abstention est un
phénomène absolument mortifère pour
notre démocratie mais quand en salle des
professeurs depuis deux trois ans on
entend des collègues de plus en plus
nombreux se poser la question du vote
quel qu'il soit
du vote aux élections
ça devrait toutes et tous vous
interpeller
voilà ensuite sur les d'autres éléments
qui ont été d'autres questions qui qui
ont été posées sur la question dans des
rémunérations j'y suis revenu sur la
question du pacte est-ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui des des éléments de
comparaison alors entre lycée général
technologique collège lycée
professionnel c'est encore assez confus
ce qu'on sait que c'est que en lycée
général et technologique ça prend
vraiment très peu parce que de toute
façon la mesure phare qui est le
remplacement de courte durée il s'adapte
absolument pas aux emplois du temps de
la réforme du lycée et que de toute
façon de manière générale que soit en
collège en lycée général et
technologique ou un lycée professionnel
le pacte ne passe pas pour ce qu'il est
c'est à dire une surcharge de travail et
par rapport à ce que je disais sur la
crédibilité de la parole politique c'est
en fait les collègues vivent ça comme on
fait reposer sur vous professeur qui est
en place la responsabilité d'assurer des
choses que l'institution n'est pas en
mesure d'assurer vers l'institution
n'est pas en mesure d'assurer les
remplacements et je me dis bah c'est
vous qui êtes déjà là et qui allait le
faire donc il y a certainement et que si
le ministère produit un jour des
statistiques on verra des différences
entre collèges lycée général
technologique et lycée professionnel
mais de manière générale puisqu'on a
aussi mené une enquête sur le pacte
qu'on est en train de dépouiller on voit
quand même que de toute façon sur ce
point-là le le on est très loin des
objectifs ministériels sur la question
qui a été posée sur
les contractuels effectivement il y a de
plus en plus de contractuels dans
l'éducation nationale qui sont en
situation de très grande précarité c'est
quelque chose qui nous alerte pour ses
collègues mais aussi je dirais pour le
statut de de fonctionnaires puisqu'on
sait à quel point la contractualisation
en tout cas nous c'est l'analyse qu'on
fait est un danger est un danger parce
que elle la contractualisation protège
beaucoup moins que que le statut est
moins protecteur donc oui la
contractualisation prendre l'ampleur
mais c'est quelque chose qui nous
inquiète et ça ne semble pas être la
voix à en ce qui concerne les
enseignants débutants quelle mesure à
prendre pour améliorer l'entrée dans le
métier il nous semble qu'une entrée
progressive dans le métier c'est à dire
pas comme c'est le cas actuellement à 18
enfin en tout cas dans le second degré à
18h ou 15h d'emblée mais avec un tiers
de service puis une moitié de service en
deuxième année de titularisation
permettrait d'accompagner du mieux
possible les enseignants qui commencent
avec également un tuteur qui joue
vraiment le rôle de celui qui accompagne
et non pas de celui qui est à la fois
accompagne et évalu parce que le tuteur
qui évalue ça ça biais quand même un peu
la relation qui peut qui peut exister
deux points pour pour terminer sur la
question du du harcèlement de la lutte
contre le harcèlement de manière plus
générale je voudrais rappeler une chose
il y a un triptyque qui est absolument
fondamental en matière de lutte contre
le harcèlement c'est prévention recueil
de l'information qu'on concernant les
élèves et après sanction avec également
une dimension éducative moi je voudrais
vous alert sur la question de la
prévention c'est le point essentiel si
on veut éradiquer le harcèlement de nos
établissements scolaires pourquoi il y a
du harcèlement enfin quelle est la
nature du harcèlement c'est parce que
finalement il y a des différences qui
sont pointées et des élèves n'acceptent
pas les différences et donc finalement
la prévention du harcèlement elle doit
passer aussi par tout un tas de
programmes de lutte contre les LGBTI
phobies lutte contre le racisme etc sur
pour finir sur la question d'Emmanuel
Macron qui
pense enfin dit que l'éducation et son
domaine réservé donc ça nous pose une
question une question démocratique un
domaine réservé est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'on a plus le droit de discuter ça
c'est quand même une question et
jusqu'ici alors vous allez me dire ça
fait un mois que c'est avec ça dure
c'est quand même venu percuter le cours
de l'éducation nationale par des
annonces mais aussi par le fond c'est à
dire que ça déboussole beaucoup les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale que
le président est un cap est un projet
pour pour l'école c'est tout à fait
normal on est en démocratie il y a
différents projets qui s'expriment
dans la façon de faire et dans la façon
d'écouter ce que les organisations
syndicales peuvent dire on a quelques
craintes sur sur la façon dont ça sera
fait et juste sur la masterisation il me
semble que en tout cas c'est fait su que
le bac +5 et le bon niveau de
recrutement puisqu'il assure une
maîtrise des savoirs disciplinaires qui
permettent d'asseoir ensuite la
professionnalité des des enseignants il
nous reste ensuite à travailler comment
est-ce qu'on prépare comment on fait en
sorte que nos collègues futurs collègues
puissent préparer au mieux le concours
et surtout entrer dans le métier de
manière progressive je m'excuse d'avoir
été un peu longue mais il me semblait
nécessaire de répondre à certains propos
qui nous ont été adressés et qui
n'étaient pas acceptables
merci
du coup je ne reviendrai pas sur les
propos effectivement qui ont été
inacceptables j'ai été choqué par la
déclaration les déclarations de certains
ont certaines d'entre vous après je suis
ravie pareil que certains ou certaines
d'entre vous aient pu percevoir l'humour
dans nos déclarations c'est rassurant de
savoir qu'on peut faire rire
concernant différentes questions qui ont
été posées
le pacte le pacte ne fonctionne pas
puisque il a été comment dire annoncé et
refusé par l'ensemble des syndicats
parce que ce n'était pas cohérent avec
une façon de travailler en établissement
ils ne fonctionnent pas parce qu'il y
avait des choses qui étaient
subordonnées à d'autres ou qui ont été
entendus comme tel
vous posez la question de savoir s'il y
avait des pressions de la part des chefs
d'établissement ou des recettes sur des
enseignants on va pas parler de pression
chacun fait son travail à son niveau le
recteur a démission le chef
d'établissement a démission chacun
essaye de faire passer les choses comme
comme il peut et il peut arriver que un
chef d'établissement Vienne négocier
avec des enseignants pour que une partie
du pacte puisse être effectuée
il n'y a pas que les renseignements les
pardons les remplacements de courte
durée j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure les
remplacements de courte durée
s'effectuer très bien avant qu'on mette
en place ce bac il n'y avait pas besoin
de contraindre les gens à ce point
concernant l'attractivité du métier une
des premières revendications de nos
organisations ce sont bien sûr les
salaires je reviens pas sur ce qui a été
dit avant puisque nous n'avons pas été
revalorisés à notre juste valeur il y a
aussi
la formation des enseignants à peut-être
à revoir même si ces revues
régulièrement et l'année de stage qui
est effectivement très très lourde pour
les pour les personnels
concernant les contractuels on en arrive
à embaucher des contractuels
parce qu'il n'y a pas assez de
professeurs remplaçant entre autres tous
les professeurs remplaçants sont déjà
pris à la rentrée sur des postes des
remplacements de moyenne ou de longue
durée voire à l'année et ce sont des
personnels dont on a vu la quotité
baissée régulièrement dans les académies
depuis des années ça date pas d'hier
concernant le harcèlement je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ma collègue Sophie
bénédicité la prévention c'est
la chose qu'on fait le moins par manque
de temps par manque de personnel par
manque de fond dans un établissement
pour pouvoir s'occuper de la prévention
du harcèlement il faut des personnels
les vie scolaires les infirmières les
psychologues de l'éducation nationale
les assistantes sociales et vous avez
une instance qui réunit bien tout ça
c'est ce sont les ces comités comité
d'éducation à la santé et la citoyenneté
et à l'écologie
j'arrête
oui je pour le seu une ça je vais
continuer notamment sur les questions
des coll inclusives de diagnostics
d'accueil des élèves je regrette que
madame la députée ait quittait la salle
parce que j'aurais pu
faire un un petit exemple sur ce qui se
passe quand un élève par exemple
attaque en premier
quelque part c'est parce qu'il est pas
bien
et il convient de s'interroger sur nous
enseignons
formés à s'interroger pourquoi une telle
manifestation pourquoi
un tel une telle agitation des remarques
déplacées bon voilà et il convient de la
part des enseignants de rester calmes
face à ce que présente cet élève voilà
l'école inclusive c'est ça
mais quand je dis ça j'ai pas tout dit
donc il y a ce qui est présenté et ce
qui est derrière ce qui est derrière
c'est quelque chose qui est très
difficile pour les collègues
actuellement
on parle de rupture le seu- une ça on
dit on est arrivé à un point de rupture
et quel est le projet qu'on veut
il y a des demandes parfois très
compliquées
de parce qu'on a fait croire
aux familles il y a que ben on allait
mettre un cartable sur le dos d'un élève
on allait lui mettre un une aesh et puis
pauvre tout allait bien il allait à
l'école et puis les enseignants allaient
se débrouiller avec tout ça sauf que
c'est faux
il faut des moyens il faut des moyens
médicaux il faut des moyens infirmiers
il faut que autour de ces élèves et ont
fragile on leur doit le respect on leur
doit l'accueil et c'est de plus en plus
compliqué
autre chose sur
le parcours d'un élève le parcours d'un
élève il est pas toujours vous êtes très
certainement parents d'élèves et il y a
des fois où Ben les notes qui vous ont
ramené c'était quand même pas tout à
fait ça le parcours d'un élève il peut
être très prendre des chemins un peu
détournés le parcours d'un élève en
situation de handicap c'est
je dirais pour en simplifiant à peu près
la même chose ces élèves sont fragiles
ces élèves sont fatigables les familles
vivent parfois dès le journées longues
souvent les mers je m'en excuse pour les
messieurs qui sont autour de la table
et parfois ces élèves ont besoin de
quitter momentanément je dirais la
scolarité ordinaire pour aller dans des
dans des établissements spécialisés
c'est pour cela que nous et ceux une ça
nous demandons des places dans les
établissements spécialisés
le
les discours qui sont tenus actuellement
suite à la CNH et au CNCPH 12 inquiète
énormément
ses enfants ont besoin un moment d'aller
à leur rythme et le système scolaire
français ne leur donne pas
autre chose sur le diagnostic madame la
députée
ce dont ont besoin ce qu'on besoin de
savoir les enseignants c'est les
conséquences que le retentissement que
va avoir le handicap sur la scolarité de
l'élève moi moi on me dit par exemple
je sais pas il a une tétraplégie droite
plus
une je sais pas trop quoi une difficulté
respiratoire et un problème
aux membres inférieurs mais bon
qu'est-ce que je vais en faire de ça par
contre si on me dit effectivement il va
avoir du mal à tenir un crayon il va
avoir du mal à tenir assis c'est ça dont
on besoin de savoir les enseignants
c'est pas forcément le diagnostic c'est
le retentissement et je crois parfois
que pour les colères les collègues
ce c'est un peu enfin
cette cette subtilité parfois un peu
compliquée à entendre voilà
sur
je crois aussi que le
manque de moyens sur sur l'inclusion
scolaire sur le domaine de le vapeur va
entraîner nos collègues vers des refus
vers des choses de plus en plus
compliquées alors qu'au départ quand
même il y a un sondage Ifop qui a été
sorti il y a début septembre fait par un
collectif d'associations de parents donc
on peut pas dire que quand même c'est
des gens qui a priori étaient contre
était contre l'inclusion
81 à 91% des enseignants étaient pour
le problème c'est comment on arrive à
déraper à ce point pour que des
collègues soient en souffrance et en
difficulté c'est ça et c'est ce qui se
passe et les écrans de fumée qu'on a vu
là ça masque tout ça et c'est bien
dommage les vraies questions
elles ne sont pas posées pendant qu'on
s'agit dans tous les sens je vous
remercie
merci pour
le FO
et merci alors sur la question qui a été
posée sur le domaine réservé du
président Macron oui c'est on constate
une un mode un mode de gouvernance qui
est que l'on subit ça
démarrait mais on pourrait situer un des
débuts à Marseille avec la logique de
l'expérimentation marseillaise qui a
vocation à être étendue sur le tout le
territoire à travers les sénères et la
logique de l'école faisons-la ensemble
qui a pour objectif d'exploser le cadre
national et d'avoir des des projets
locaux partout et donc ça rejoint la
question qui avait été posée sur le plus
d'autonomie
qui nous ne nous convient pas nous
rappelons notre attachement auprès de
relationnel et républicains de l'école
le pacte qui est directement connecté à
cette logique qui met en place un
contrat individuel avec des missions qui
s'attaquent aux statut par exemple
prenons l'exemple de la modification des
statuts qui permet maintenant les
d'envoyer les PE et les professeurs des
écoles au collège que ce soit aussi
la mise en place des réformes donc
encore une fois avec les référents pour
mettre en place les les projets locaux
contre les postes avec les remplacements
courte durée par exemple ou les poses
spécialisés puisque on a beaucoup parlé
des cols inclusives on partage ce cette
inquiétude mais une des missions du
pacte c'est d'avoir des référents qui
viendraient se substituer au nécessaire
classe et poste spécialisés pour prendre
en charge le suivi les élèves en
fonction de leur situation et pour leur
garantir un enseignant adapté que ce
soit aussi toutes les missions qui
relèvent de la voie professionnelle qui
vise à transformer les lycées
professionnels aux choses que ce qu'ils
sont actuellement et promouvoir
l'apprentissage et en fonction du besoin
des entreprises exclusivement donc oui
on assiste à un passage en force
même si au ministère parfois les souvent
les propos sont plus polis que ce qu'on
a pu entendre mais il y a également
cette méthode
de gouvernance ou
en quelque soit ce qui est dit on les a
cherché à avancer que ce soit par le
biais d'annonce alors sur d'autres
questions qui ont été posées
alors sur le la question les abats je
vais pas y revenir mais sur le non sur
la nous ne sommes pas demandeurs d'une
tenue
particulière pour nous c'est l'égalité
de traitement
et au niveau compris des apprentissages
qui garantit
la cohésion de l'école de la République
pas une pas une tenue quelconque sur la
question qui a été posée sur le
harcèlement on nous dit que c'est la
nouvelle priorité et la du gouvernement
mais
en quoi ça va consister taper sur les
lampes pistes ou alors
se remettre en question les suppressions
de poste auxquelles on assiste on a
décrit le manque de personnel que soit
chef d'établissement adjoint que soit
les personnels de vie scolaire les AED
qui sont en manque Crillon partout que
ce soit les CPE les infirmières les
assistants sociaux quand on veut suivre
les élèves et les prendre en charge
c'est
[Musique]
des questions
merci
oui alors pour le Gun CFDT on va essayer
de répondre à la plupart des questions
sur on va commencer par la question nous
a été posée pour réduire les cas de
salaire avec les autres cadres A
qu'elles étaient nos revendications nous
pose la question je peux donner trois
revendications du Zen
la mise en oeuvre d'un plan pluriannuel
de revalorisation des rémunérations et
pas des tâches ou des missions
supplémentaires
très concrètement le triplement des de
l'Isoe et Lise à eux et des primes
équivalentes pour les autres personnels
par rapport au niveau de 2020 jusque là
il y a eu un doublement mais pour le
second CFDT ce n'est qu'une étape
et puis on propose aussi de remettre
dans l'école l'argent qui est dépensé
pour le SNU donc voilà trois moyens pour
réduire l'écart avec les autres cadres
sur les difficultés des enseignants en
début de carrière alors la question est
très complexe mais pour pointer juste
une chose il faudrait
repenser retravailler l'articulation
qu'il y a entre les inspects et les
universités parce que c'est
l'accumulation
d'attente et d'exigences qui viennent de
deux entités différentes qui est une des
parties une des parties mais une des
parties du problème
sur
l'école qui serait domaine réservé du
président
pour le gain CFDT Catherine naveti la
secrétaire général l'a très bien
formulée l'école ne doit pas être un
domaine réservé mais au contraire ce
doit être en domaine partagé c'est
forcément une mauvaise piste que de
suivre celle
sur les je suis un peu à la volée sur
les conséquences de la masterisation
je vais pas apporter de réponse à ça
mais en tout cas nous on a eu un point
de vigilance quelque chose qui nous a
beaucoup inquiété dans les dernières
semaines oui dans les dernières semaines
derniers mois je ne sais plus exactement
quand l'idée est apparue que peut-être
on pourrait décrocher la formation des
PE professeur des écoles avec celle des
professeurs du second degré pour nous
c'est une très mauvaise piste les PE et
les professeurs du second degré devrait
même appartenir à encore unique et donc
avoir le même niveau de recrutement
enfin restez en tout cas au même niveau
de recrutement
sur les freins à la signature du pacte
alors
j'ai hésité n'en prenant mes notes je me
suis dit je suis repartir sur le
désarroi qu'on a à voir tout ce qu'on
fait qui avait mais bon tout ça on l'a
déjà dit
des missions supplémentaires enfin
qu'est-ce qui freine les collègues on
vous a une des collègues ici présente à
déjà dit qu'on adepte à combien la dette
estime le nombre d'heures de travail par
semaine enfin à un moment accumuler des
missions supplémentaires c'est juste
plus possible voilà donc quel est le
principal frein le pad ce sont des
missions supplémentaires
sur une question a été posée sur comment
obtenir le comptage des élèves Ulysse
moi
comment dire les dispositifs Ulysse à ma
connaissance en tout cas dans mon
département c'est comme ça ils sont
toujours plein donc au moment des CSA
qui examinent la carte scolaire et bien
il suffit de mettre le dispositif à son
nombre plan et de le considérer dans la
comment dire dans le nombre d'élèves de
l'école enfin ça paraît pas plus
compliqué que ça vu que de toute façon
les dispositifs seront plein donc on est
après effectivement ça implique quoi ça
implique que budgétairement on est donné
à cette poste pour qu'il y ait des
professeurs effectivement devant tous
les élèves qui existent mais les élèves
du Lys ils existent donc quand on est
puisqu'ils seront là
et puis je vais faire la transition pour
donner la parole à ma collègue sur
harcèlement et bien-être sur enfin je
remets le bien-être parce que c'était
aussi dans les questions qu'on nous
avait transmises mais sur le harcèlement
comme sur le bien-être il est évident
que il y a aucune solution simpliste qui
sera la solution et puis il y a pas de
solution uniquement enfin une solution
simple en vêtement c'est sûr et certain
que ça ne réglera absolument rien comme
par magie et je rejoins aussi les propos
qui ont été dites par les collègues
précédemment c'est que il faut de la
prévention de la prévention primaire
c'est-à-dire que sur le harcèlement sur
le bien-être on est dans la réaction
quand il y a des événements dramatiques
qui arrivent mais en fait il faudrait
déjà repense fin
changer et se mettre à observer l'école
et à accepter de prendre le temps de
penser d'école déjà comme un cadre
bienveillant et ça ça résoudrait bien
des choses à ma collègue va peut-être
développer sur cet aspect là oui je vais
essayer d'être très rapide pour laisser
la parole à mes à mes collègues
le bien-être des élèves oui on aimerait
déjà nous être bien pour pouvoir donner
le meilleur de nous-mêmes pour ce
bien-être là la question nous semble
essentielle elle n'a pas été reposée là
aujourd'hui donc
ce n'est pas une priorité de l'éducation
nationale le bien-être des élèves les
besoins de nos élèves leur bien-être ne
sont pas réfléchis l'école et les
organisée autour de programme
d'évaluation d'ailleurs national et donc
non adapté aux élèves que les
enseignants ont en face 2 et d'examens
qui trient les élèves le rapport sur
l'état des services publics publiés par
nos services publics dressent un constat
que la prise en compte des besoins des
enfants apparaît comme le principal
impensé de l'institution scolaire vous
nous avez posé la question on ne voulait
pas vous quitter sans vous le redire je
reprends un exemple que j'avais gardé de
qu'à évoqué une collecte tout à l'heure
pour qu'un élève se sente bien en milieu
scolaire il doit d'abord être un enfant
qui va bien or 35% de la population
active se prive d'un repas par jour il y
a dans nos écoles des enfants qui ont
faim et le cadre très contraint de notre
école ne laisse aucun espace pour
prendre ses réalités en compte nos
jeunes l'attractivité des métiers nos
jeunes qui arrivent nos jeunes
stagiaires qui arrivent dans les écoles
et qui font ces constats-là croyez-vous
qu'ils ont la force de se dire je vais y
arriver voilà surtout quand on a des
propos comme ceux qui ont été tenus tout
à l'heure je suis horrifiée de ce qui a
été dit et je n'ai jamais je n'aurais
pensé que ça aurait pu être dit ici dans
une telle assemblée
j'arrive en fin de carrière
moi j'ai qu'une envie là j'ai jamais
j'ai envie de vous dire je touche 2400
euros j'ai 60 ans dans l'année
que voulez-vous qu'on puisse entendre ça
et encore je suis bien parce que je suis
dans ma famille bien j'ai un conjoint
qui me soutient j'ai travaillé toute ma
vie les collèges mais je ne suis pas la
seule je suis une représentante imaginez
le nombre de collègues qui sont dans
notre cas avec un bac + 5 avec un père
qui était tourneur-fraiseur
l'éducation c'est vraiment le faire de
lance de la société de demain et c'est
scandaleux qui a été dit là
et je ne parle pas en mon nom mais parce
que vous avez besoin d'exemples concrets
parce que sinon on n'est pas crédible et
puis on se fait traiter de voilà de
caricatures donc non je ne suis pas une
caricature je suis une représentante de
tous les collègues qui sont dans la même
situation
on a besoin d'éducation moi je suis très
satisfaite d'avoir eu cette chance là il
faut que nos élèves lents et au-delà des
exemples dramatiques pour tous les
élèves le bien-être n'est pas pensé on
terminerait sur une petite anecdote pour
un petit peu mais je sais pas de la joie
je suis pas sûr que ce soit très joyeux
le manque criant de toilette faites le
calcul quand dans un collège de 600
élèves il y a un unique espace toilette
fille avec 10 cabines fonctionnels et
quatre robinets d'eau est-ce que là on
n'est pas en train de parler de
bien-être aussi respectons aussi nos
élèves donnons-leur l'envie d'être bien
pour pouvoir bien apprendre merci
merci
il faut que vous il faut juste voilà
merci voilà merci je vais essayer d'être
rapide sur la question déjà je vais pas
revenir sur sur on n'est pas venu ici
pour jouer une pièce de théâtre
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour le théâtre et de passer
pour des guignols parce que là vraiment
c'est très chaud quand sur la question
des salaires et bien comme mes collègues
nous sommes c'est les 10% qui nous qui
nous manquent et plus largement on est
pour une refonte des grilles on est
aussi sur la ligne du corps unique et
une grille tout au long de la carrière
qui ne soit pas non plus soumise à des
évaluations par les inspecteurs
c'est-à-dire une grille d'évolution de
carrière sans sans contrepartie de de
promotion enfin accéléré
pour la question des salaires et
pourquoi on se pose aussi la question de
il y a on recrute de plus en plus de
contractuels le métier n'attire pas
alors c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
encore abordé c'est aussi la question de
la mobilité
il y a un gros problème dans notre
ministère de de sclérose j'allais dire
quasiment totale de la mobilité et ça ça
n'attire pas parce que quand vous savez
que vous allez rester des années et des
années dans le même département et que
vous voulez rejoindre votre famille ou
repartir dans votre département
d'origine et bien dans certains
départements c'est extrêmement compliqué
et moi même on pense aux grandes
académies comme Versailles ou Créteil
mais moi j'habite un petit département
qui est l'Allier et bien il est très
difficile de le quitter parce qu'ils
veulent rejoindre le Puy-de-Dôme dans le
premier degré et ben il faut avoir un
1000 points pour pouvoir sortir de
l'Allier parce que personne veut venir
dans l'Allier et que il y avait beaucoup
d'étudiants originaires depuis d'hommes
et très naturellement ils ont envie de
retourner dans le Puy-de-Dôme
sur les contractuels
et bien écoutez il y a une solution très
simple c'est à dire que nous on pense
qu'il faut les titulariser immédiatement
sans condition
et ensuite on passe au concours et
terminé il n'y a plus de contractuels
comme l'a dit la collègue du SNES les
contractuels c'est une attaque directe
au statut
voilà donc la question des contractuels
elle peut être vite réglée sur la
masterisation et j'allais dire sur le
début de carrière bien nous on est
effectivement il faut reconnaître le
niveau master aux enseignants mais on
est pour un concours en licence comme
c'était avant la réforme sur la
masterisation le concours au Master et
par contre deux ans deux formations et
d'entrée progressif dans le métier après
la licence donc le concours et puis deux
ans de formation et une entrée
progressive dans le métier et deux ans
sous statut de fonctionnaires stagiaires
voilà et puis on parlait des inégalités
des questions des fournitures des
familles qui ont de plus en plus de mal
par rapport à la scolarité des
transports bon bah il y a je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure il y a des communes qui
pratiquent la gratuité des fournitures
et il y en a d'autres qui demandent aux
familles de tout acheter bah ça il
faudrait qui est une j'allais dire une
un cadrage de qui viennent du ministère
parce que c'est pas possible qui est des
inégalités pareilles selon l'endroit où
on habite
selon son origine sociale culturelle et
c'est pas que en milieu urbain parce que
je le redis j'habite dans un département
donc très rural et je peux vous dire la
misère culturelle de sociale elle dit
aussi et puis la dernière chose c'est
sur l'école inclusive oui on est en
train de malheureusement faire une
fabrique de rejets de l'école inclusive
et ça c'est très très grave chaque
enfant a le droit à sa scolarisation il
y a des milliers d'enfants à la rentrée
qui ne peuvent pas être scolarisés qui
n'ont les notifications MDPH ne sont pas
appliquées il n'y a pas d'aosh où il n'y
a pas d'aménagement possible il n'y a
pas d'accompagnement possible c'est
intolérable on peut pas dire que dans ce
pays en France des enfants sont privés
de scolarité parce qu'on n'a pas mis les
moyens en face
et les moyens en face ce sont des
enseignants spécialisés je les dis tout
à l'heure alors il y a beaucoup de
postes vacants d'enseignants spécialisés
bien je vous le mets dans le mille qui
c'est qui va sur ses postes
d'enseignants spécialisés ce sont des
contractuels
voilà il y a la question des aesh 130
000 85% des aesh sont un bac à bac + 4
maintenant il faut cesser les aesh
doivent être reconnus c'est un métier
c'est un métier qui doit être reconnu
par un statut qui doit être reconnu par
un salaire qui est à la hauteur de la
technicité c'est un métier de femme
comme l'a dit ma camarade de sud et bien
souvent on observe que quand c'est un
métier féminisé bizarrement et bien les
questions de salaire sont vraiment
j'allais dire secondaire
et que nous nous disent pas qu'on va
faire un deuxième métier qui va leur
permettre d'avoir un temps complet moi
je vous pose la question messieurs et
mesdames ici qui peut accompagner des
élèves en situation de handicap être au
portail du collège faire appeller les
parents pour les absences allez faire la
cantine sur 41 heures par semaine
puisque le temps est annualisé qui peut
faire ça pour 1200 euros
non soyons sérieux c'est quand même pas
possible donc ça c'est un vrai vrai
problème voilà donc j'en ai fini puis je
vais il va dire deux mots sur sur les
autres questions
très rapidement sur les sur les
pressions sur le sur la signature du
pack les pressions pour les chefs
d'établissement oui on a des remontées
de situations dépression plus ou moins
directes plus ou moins formelles des
pressions via des emplois du temps
dégradés donc après est-ce que
augmenter
les parfums des heures dans un emploi du
temps est-ce que c'est pas un moyen
aussi de pousser un collègue à signer
des pressions via les autorisations
d'absence des collègues à qui on répond
à l'oral pour une demande d'autorisation
d'absence par exemple pour partir sur
une journée de formation trouvez-vous
des collègues pour assurer votre
emplacement de courte durée donc
dépression on envoie déjà remonter
depuis la rentrée sur la question du
domaine réservé présidentielle
ce qu'on peut voir c'est que c'est ça
augmente le déni de réalité du terrain
et ça augmente le côté la politique
idéologique sur l'école et si on regarde
sur l'exemple de la réforme de la voix
de la voix professionnelle on retrouve
des rengaines sur le lycée professionnel
qui aurait été coupé du monde en
entreprise qui était on sait que c'est
faux parce que les collègues vont
régulièrement justement faire des
visites d'entreprise une méthode
purement idéologique sur le le où on
donne un objectif quasiment unique sur
la session professionnelle le lycée
professionnel et la vocation assuré bien
évidemment une insertion professionnelle
mais aussi d'accès à une culture
générale de haut niveau et la volonté
présidentielle de nous piloter la carte
des formations que par les taux
d'insertion va mécaniquement en ignorant
la demande sociale produire du
décrochage et ça pour le coup c'est dans
les endroits où l'offre en format de
formation en tertiaire déjà été dégradé
on peut déjà le constater on constate
aussi une autre chose c'est il y a une
misère qui augmente il y a eu l'alerte
de lancer par les Restos du Coeur à la
rentrée mais on voit la misère qui
augmente il y a des lycéens qui
contactent le 115 pour pour dormir dans
des établissements des collègues
organisent des collègues de nourriture
et produits d'hygiène pour les élèves il
y a un problème de manque de place en
internat il y a une à l'heure actuelle
on voit qu'il y a une dégradation de
l'offre alimentaire par les
collectivités territoriales alors que la
cantine le midi est souvent le seul
repas équilibré voir le seul repas et le
il y a des régions notamment la région
Île-de-France qui sur la ce qu'on
appelle la dotation de solidarité
pratique des seuils différents des
médias différents en fonction des
catégories d'élèves
en prenant en compte l'IPS même avec des
catégories différentes ce qui amène à
donner moins aux établissements qui
concentre le plus de difficultés
merci
pour le snack et je laisserai mon
collègue compléter sur la question de
l'école inclusive sans les moyens de
l'école inclusive
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier les
députés qui sont encore là
merci à vous de continuer à nous écouter
voilà c'est on se voit une fois par an
depuis l'année dernière voilà allez
trois heures dans l'année je trouve que
c'est quand même intéressant d'avoir le
retour des organisations présentatives
pour la commission éducation et de ce
point de vue là je ne doute pas que ceux
qui ne sont pas là regardons le replay
plus sérieusement oui nous sommes élus
il faut quand même s'en rendre compte
c'est quelque chose que nous partageons
avec vous d'ailleurs c'est l'élection et
effectivement il y a
comme chez vous mais j'ai envie de dire
en ce moment peut-être moins que chez
vous des divergences entre les
organisations syndicales représentatives
moi ce qui m'inquiéterait mais ce qui
devrait peut-être vous inquiéter c'est
qu'il y a de moins en moins de
divergences entre nos organisations
syndicales représentatives moi
j'écoutais par exemple ma collègue de
Sud alors il y avait au moins un point
où effectivement on n'avait pas on
n'avait pas la même position
néanmoins il y en avait quand même
beaucoup on était d'accord
c'est vous dire où en est l'état de
l'école pour qu'on en arrive nous tous
et toutes ici à signer de plus en plus
de documents inter syndicaux de
communication inter syndicale
ce n'est pas
un hasard voilà c'est que je crois qu'on
a toutes et tous ici parce qu'on y est
dans nos classes moi aussi je suis
toujours devant élève on a toutes et
tous compris
que là l'école elle est dans une
situation qu'on a probablement jamais
connu alors on peut discuter de tas de
sujets annexes ils sont pas forcément
complètement sans intérêt néanmoins
on va aller où là on va on va continuer
à laisser notre école se dégrader on va
continuer à laisser les gens ne plus
vouloir faire nos métiers on va
continuer à laisser augmenter les
départs volontaires dans nos métiers pas
que chez les enseignants on parlait des
aesh et de plus en plus d'avesh qui s'en
vont aussi c'est pas étonnant
regardez leur salaire regardez leurs
conditions de travail
voilà c'est pas étonnant que des gens
aille chercher ailleurs y compris
parfois dans des métiers qui paraît qui
paraissent à première vue beaucoup moins
attractif et sympathique mais qui en
fait le son plus attractif et
sympathique quand on voit comment on les
traite dans le premier employeur de
France l'éducation nationale
voilà vraiment moi je m'en moque qui
arrive au snack on s'en moque de votre
couleur politique aux uns aux autres
c'est pas notre sujet vous faites ce que
vous faites de la politique c'est très
bien mais à un moment l'école c'est un
bien commun de la République c'est un
des piliers fondamentaux du
fonctionnement de notre pays
il est en train de se casser la figure
ce pilier alors vraiment nous on n'est
pas très intéressé par
voilà toute l'écume qu'on a et les
choses envoyées de manière pas toujours
très agréable et on est bien d'accord ça
a pas commencé il y a 6 ans il y a eu un
avant Emmanuel Macron et ça allait déjà
pas très bien c'est tout n'est pas à
mettre sur le dos qui s'est passé c'est
six dernières années c'est un processus
beaucoup plus long bien entendu
néanmoins à un moment c'est nous qui
sommes là c'est vous qui êtes là et ce
qu'on fait quelque chose est-ce qu'on
essaie de sauver l'école de la
République ou est-ce qu'on la laisse là
voilà bon elle se relèvera pas là je
pense que elle se relèvera pas d'ici
quelques années ce sera fini
voilà du coup je vais devoir aller très
très vite sur les réponses plus précises
mais je vais faire au mieux sur le
harcèlement le SNAL qui a demandé alors
au ministre précédent mais du coup on va
demander au nouveau un bilan du
programme PHARE parce que c'est bien
beau de généraliser le programme
anti-harcèlement que l'on a dans notre
dans notre système éducatif
encore faut-il s'assurer qu'il est
efficace et qu'il est efficace dans
toutes les situations nous on a de
sérieux doute sur le sujet on pense
qu'il est plutôt efficace sur les petits
harcèlements c'est-à-dire sur ce ou une
prise de conscience de l'élève harceleur
qui était allé trop loin qui s'en était
pas rendu compte là le programme phare a
priori fonctionne plutôt bien sur les
cartes de harcèlement les plus graves on
n'est pas certain qu'il fonctionne on se
demande même si dans certains cas il
n'est pas contre-productif donc on
aimerait déjà qu'on voit un petit peu
avant de généraliser quelque chose qu'on
est des données à peu précises et
objectives sur comment cela fonctionne
ça nous changerait dans l'éducation
nationale parce que les généralisations
sans avoir fait le bilan on est quand
même les spécialistes sur les démissions
de stagiaires l'entrée progressive dans
le métier il y a de plus en plus de
démission de stagiaires nous on pense
que le concours en fin de M2 c'était une
stupidité non enfin je pense qu'on est
pas les seuls puisque je crois qu'on est
tous voté contre de ce point de vue là
effectivement il faut que le concours
ait lieu plutôt alors on peut discuter
bac + 3 bacs + 4 et il faut une entrée
progressive dans le métier aujourd'hui
je rappelle que les stagiaires en master
métier de l'éducation entre à temps
plein devant élèves voilà temps complet
devant élève faut pas s'étonner si
certains repartent assez vite il
faudrait probablement même deux ans
d'entrée progressive dans le métier avec
effectivement de l'alternance aller voir
différents établissements différents
niveaux du système éducatif ce serait
probablement beaucoup plus intéressant
sur les contractuels
une fois encore déjà le travail c'est
quand même d'essayer d'attirer des
titulaires et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
contractuels pourraient passer des
concours il y a des voies spécifiques
pour les contractuels beaucoup n'en ont
pas envie parce que effectivement le
concours n'est pas attractif y compris
pour eux si vous êtes contractuel dans
une académie plutôt attractive passer le
concours effectivement c'est pas
forcément l'idée du siècle parce que
vous allez vous retrouver très très loin
de chez vous par exemple alors vous
serez peut-être un peu mieux payé mais
je suis pas certain que vous y gagnerez
donc il faut effectivement que notre
métier notre concours soit absolument
beaucoup plus attractif c'est comme ça
aussi qu'on attirera des étudiants qu'on
attirera des contrat actuels et que à un
moment les contractuels qu'on a pour
certains deviendront des titulaires ça
nous paraît essentiel
sur les pressions sur le pacte on en a
très clairement je peux pas vous les
quantifier je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement il y a eu des pressions
sur des voyages et des sorties scolaires
il y a des pressions sur le fait de
partir en formation si on n'a pas
soi-même trouvé quelqu'un pour nous
remplacer par exemple on a des pressions
sur le fait de prendre le pacte en 6e
avec la mission devoirs fait pour
pouvoir être professeur principal de 6e
mais en fait il y a pas impact on est en
train d'avoir impact par école ou par
rétablissement et ce qui est marqué dans
les textes réglementaires parfois n'est
même pas respecté au niveau de tel ou
telle établissement et alors ce qui est
marqué dans la note de service et
respecter même pas la moitié du temps
donc ça va être très compliqué de faire
un bilan de ce pack parce qu'on ne sait
même pas de quoi il est constitué dans
tel collège dans tel lycée dans tel
école
sur
la masturisation j'en ai parlé nous on
pense qu'il faut garder un niveau master
puisqu'on est là ça paraît compliqué de
revenir en arrière à notre sens
maintenant ça veut pas dire que il faut
que le concours soit en bac + 5 un point
e s h et je te laisse la parole sur
l'inclusion on a beaucoup parlé du
métier d'aesh c'est pour ça que nous on
pense que c'est un vrai métier et que ce
qui est proposé c'est à dire de faire un
métier qui fusionne les compétences des
aesh et des assistants d'éducation c'est
une folie totale avec la Conférence
nationale du handicap je sais pas qui a
eu cette idée là dedans mais c'est
honteux d'avoir proposé ça et
effectivement un métier avec plus de 130
000 personnes dans la fonction publique
un métier pérenne normalement ça demande
un statut de la fonction publique et ça
ça aussi c'est de votre responsabilité
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
passerait par une loi donc à un moment
si on veut fidéliser nos aesh et si on
veut que ce métier soit reconnu et mieux
payé et mieux exercés ça passe par un
statut Xavier sur l'école inclusive de
manière un peu plus globale oui merci
l'école c'est du tendon le handicap
aussi juste un petit point pour
compléter ce qui a été dit par plusieurs
de mes collègues la loi sur le handicap
c'est 2005 de mémoire c'est une loi qui
a été votée à l'unanimité par cette
assemblée tous les enseignants
spécialisés connaissent par cœur c'est
une accélération 2014 sauf que on inclut
plus qu'avant on fait rentrer plus
d'enfants dans l'école plus d'enfants
handicapés la question c'est comment on
les inclut et parallèlement à cette à
cet aspect purement statistique purement
chiffres on inclus les enfants
handicapés c'est la suppression des
razèdes les diminutions des postes dans
les établissements spécialisés et
parallèlement l'offre de soins parce que
nous on est concernés par ça l'offre de
soins de rééducation ou de soins en
psychiatrie parce que le psychisme c'est
dans le handicap c'est la loi
elle diminue donc on accueille de plus
en plus d'enfants à l'école mais on les
accueille mal il y a des réussites on va
pas se nier tout ne va pas mal il y a
des réussites mais il y a beaucoup
d'enfants qu'on accueille pour dire on
les a mis dans la salle de classe comme
un sachet de thé dans la tasse d'eau
chaude et ils vont infuser voilà c'est
la magie vous rentrez dans l'école ils
vont être scolarisés et éventuellement
il y a un petit peu d'Ash et on revient
pas sur leur salaire absolument
méprisable à côté de ça on n'a pas les
moyens de les accueillir correctement et
on a de plus en plus de situations de
violence ce qui pose problème aux
enseignants c'est les troubles du
comportement l'enfant qu'il faut mettre
juste au premier rang les enseignants
ils sont d'accord personne dit non toi
aussi au dernier rang parce que tu dois
le premier rang parce que je suis
méchant ça existe pas les petites
adaptations on les fait par contre les
enfants qui fuguent les enfants qui sont
violents parce qu'ils sont mal qui ont
besoin de soin de rééducation on sait
pas faire on est enseignant on n'est pas
psychologue on n'est pas psychiatre on
n'est pas infirmier or il y a les moyens
n'ont pas suivi de ce point de vue là on
est juste sur on met des absh et
statistiquement on scolarise et à côté
de ça depuis le confinement on a une
multiplication par 3 des tentatives de
suicide dans ce pays avec une
pédopsychiatrique était déjà sinistrée
dans ce pays avec des postes aux
épreuves aux ECN en médecine la
psychiatrie est une discipline qui
n'intéresse pas les étudiants et la
pédopsychiatrie intéresse encore moins
donc nous on se retrouve dans des
départements où il y a aucune offre de
soins on a des gamins qui vont mal on le
signal on n'a pas d'infirmière on a une
infirmière sur quatre établissements le
médecin scolaire n'en parlons pas il
gère 15000 élèves donc il a pas le temps
non plus de se déplacer ici c'est pas
faire ils nous disent de toute façon moi
je suis pédiatre au médecin généraliste
je suis pas pédopsychiatre et on se
retrouve avec des gamins lâchés dans la
nature qui en réalité vont pas bien qui
sont maltraités qui parfois font des
conneries pour dire les choses
clairement mais parce que ils sont mal
et on nous dit bah c'est formidable donc
les parents sont déçus et son attente
c'est tout à fait légitime mais on peut
même mettre des classes à 45 avec 10
gamins handicapés dans la classe en
statistiquement ils sont scolarisés mais
c'est pas c'est pas correct et ça fait
18 ans et ça fait des années qu'on a
l'air et qu'effectivement les collègues
même bienveillants portent parfois des
situations à bout de bras finissent par
s'épuiser et la seule réponse de
l'institution c'est en gros c'est la
pédagogie faut différencier faut adapter
l'école elle peut pas tout on a parlé
tout à l'heure de respect de laïcité etc
bah déjà ne pas demander l'école
absolument tout ou alors nous donner les
moyens de le faire sinon ça ne peut pas
marcher
sur les les remarques qui nous ont été
faites on pensait qu'avec le départ de
Jean-Michel Blanquer on en avait fini
avec le prof baching on dirait que c'est
pas arrivé jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
voilà c'est dommage
pour répondre sur les questions qui nous
ont été posées sur les salaires on a
plusieurs revendications à SUD-éducation
celle d'abord d'un rattrapage 400 euros
pour toutes et tous l'indexation du
point d'indice sur l'inflation là la
période nous montre que c'est absolument
nécessaire l'abrogation du jour de
carence qui pénalise les personnels
lorsque ils sont en arrêt pour cause de
maladie et qui pénalise d'autant plus
les femmes qui vont avoir des congés
supplémentaires en raison de
dysménorrhée ou d'endométriose par
exemple et enfin le paiement à temps
plein du temps partiel de droit pour
agir sur la rémunération en particulier
des femmes et des personnels handicapées
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale
autorise pour un certain nombre de
motifs des temps partiel sauf que c'est
les personnels qu'ils financent eux et
elles-mêmes les temps les autorisations
de temps partiel sont données pour
élever un enfant donc c'est pas
principalement les femmes quand on voit
les qu'ils prennent ou pour donner des
soins à un proche là encore c'est
majoritairement des femmes l'autre cas
c'est le handicap et donc c'est les
personnes handicapées en situation de
handicap qui se retrouvent à financer
elle-même
leur aménagement de service en quelque
sorte sur la formation initiale on nous
a demandé si l'année de stage était
acceptable non elle ne l'est pas encore
plus avec le retour des stagiaires à
temps plein c'est une vraie dégradation
de l'entrée dans le métier et l'entrée
dans le métier elle est importante parce
que c'est ce qui va aussi déterminer la
carrière les premières années les
premières classes qu'on a eu les
premières formations qu'on a suivi c'est
des formations qui vont nous marquer
pour la vie et de même pour les classes
et là on se retrouve avec des entrées
dans le métier traumatisantes difficiles
avec des souvenirs douloureux pour
beaucoup de collègues mais des tuteurs
recrutés à la rentrée par exemple ça
c'est un vrai problème il faut un
améliorer le l'accompagnement des
stagiaires dans les établissements mais
il y a pas que l'année de stage qui est
difficile l'année de M2 est impossible
entre le M2 le concours le travail en
classe
on porte comme d'autres revendications
comme d'autres organisations syndicales
présentent ici la le recrutement à bac
+3 suivi deux années de formation
rémunérées sous statut avec une entrée
progressive dans le métier ça pourrait
être par exemple une première année en
observation avec des temps en
observation en classe un retour dans les
instituts de formation
qui permettent à installer retour entre
l'observation et la réflexion critique
et puis une deuxième année avec un temps
de classe en responsabilité mais sur une
quantité évidemment incomplète pour
pouvoir permettre d'avoir une formation
en parallèle sur la question de la
reprise en main de l'école par le
Président de la République alors pour
nous le problème c'est pas qui fait les
annonces c'est qu'elles sont ces
annonces et comment elles sont décidées
si on prend l'exemple de la Conférence
nationale du handicap typiquement on a
des mesures qui sont décidées pour
l'école sans concertation aucune avec
les personnels alors qu'on a demandé à
notre ministère d'être consulté d'y
participer ça c'est un problème on va on
peut pas faire l'école sans les
personnels on peut pas faire l'école
inclusive sans les personnels
toute façon on a des annonces du
président qui sont hors sujets quand on
parle des collèges ouverts de 8h à 18h
comme si c'était une grande nouveauté en
fait dans les quartiers d'éducation
prioritaire les collèges sont ouverts au
moins jusqu'à 17h30 si ce n'est 18h
parce que les cours finissent à 16h là
donc on est en train de faire passer
pour des mesures progressives de lutte
contre les inégalités ce qui existe déjà
et ce qui est un problème parce qu'en
fait les heures de classe de 16h30 à
17h30 elles sont pas très intéressantes
au règle générale avec les élèves voilà
donc c'est surtout en fait le contenu
des annonces qui est problématiques de
même quand on dit que chaque élève de 6e
va planter un arbre nous on souhaiterait
qu'on arrête de déforester ce serait ça
une vraie mesure écologique aujourd'hui
dans notre pays
est-ce qu'il y a des pressions pour
signer le pacte oui on a énormément de
retours de collègues en particulier des
collègues non titulaires qui ont peur
pour la vie de leur c'est que les chefs
d'établissement mettent un avis
favorable ou défavorable sur le
renouvellement donc il y a une vraie
crainte pour ces personnels il y a des
le problème avec le pacte aussi ça a été
que
il a commencé à être proposer aux
personnel dans les établissements alors
que les concertations avec les
organisations syndicales n'étaient pas
terminées donc on avait encore des
réunions au ministère on discutait de la
note de service on essayait d'arrendre
la moins bien possible et puis en même
temps dans les établissements les chefs
d'établissement commençaient à dire vous
inquiétez pas vous pourrez signer le
pacte même sans faire de remplacement de
courte durée voilà donc ça c'est quand
même un principal problème et quand on
se retrouve à avoir ce genre de méthode
pour faire accepter un dispositif au
personnel c'est qu'il y a un problème
dans le dispositif à notre avis sur la
question de l'école inclusive alors il y
a la question effectivement de
l'inscription des élèves des dispositifs
en classe ordinaires on a parlé des
élèves qui sont inscrits en ULIS mais il
y a également la question des élèves
allophones dont on parle pas
suffisamment et dans des établissements
où il y a une Ulysse une peu de ça mais
effectivement on se retrouve avec des
classes qui sont déjà pleines 24 élèves
voilà et un deux trois élèves de
différents dispositifs à inclure ça veut
dire que pour les pour les personnels ça
veut dire que c'est le 25e 26e élève par
exemple en éducation prioritaire ça ça
pose un vrai souci
il faut absolument que les élèves de
dispositifs du collège soit inclus dans
les moyens du collège dans les classes
c'est des élèves qui ont droit à d'abord
des moyens donc pour leur scolarité et
puis sinon ça rend leur inclusion
absolument impossible
pour les pour les personnels
de même sur la question de l'abonnement
moyen pour les classes qui accueillent
des élèves en situation de handicap
c'est ce qui s'est fait par exemple en
Italie quand il y a eu la le
développement de ce qui était l'école
inclusive c'est une baisse du nombre
d'élèves par classe du moment qu'il y a
des élèves en situation de handicap qui
sont scolarisés dans la classe voilà ça
serait une mesure de bon sens en fait
pour l'école
mais on estime que voilà toutes ces
mesures sont nécessaires on insiste sur
la question du statut pour les avsa
parce qu'aujourd'hui les aesh ça sont
devenus un peu un symbole dans
l'éducation nationale du traitement qui
nous est fait c'est à dire vous avez vu
par exemple quand il y a des
mobilisations des personnels à bash
c'était pas seulement les personnelsh
qui étaient fortement mobilisées mais
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative et
en fait la situation qu'il aurait faite
une situation qui révolte tout le monde
on voit les conséquences pour nos
métiers pour l'accueil des élèves et qui
touchent l'ensemble des personnels
aujourd'hui si on
arrivait à gagner un statut de la
fonction publique avec un temps plein à
24 heures la reconnaissance du métier
pour les absh ça serait un pas énorme
pour l'école inclusive pour les élèves
évidemment mais également pour
l'ensemble des personnages ce sera enfin
la reconnaissance qu'on va faire l'école
inclusive mais avec des moyens ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose de primordial
aujourd'hui pour l'école et je pense que
c'est une des principales revendications
des personnels pour finir sur les élèves
qui dorment à la rue et puis la question
de l'uniforme
est-ce que l'élève les sous l'école est
en mesure de faire face à la
popularisation des familles non en fait
on l'a dit l'épaule médico-sociaux
étaient
vides dans énormément d'établissements à
la rentrée et encore plus dans les
établissements difficiles puisque les
conditions de travail sont plus plus
difficiles et moins attractives donc il
faut repenser l'éducation prioritaire il
faut mettre des moyens pour que les
enseignants et les enseignantes et les
personnes médico-sociaux et d'y rester
d'être affecté dans ces établissements
et puis il faut repenser à l'échelle des
politiques de ville la gratuité des
transports le développement des
transports publics afin de d'aider les
familles et enfin pour finir sur
l'uniforme on est on est contre les
mesures qui vont ajouter des contraintes
sur les familles on estime que
l'uniforme c'est pas du tout dans la
culture scolaire notre pays cela
engendrerait des conflits inutiles avec
les élèves et des contraintes terribles
sur les familles parce qu'on se dit même
que des familles qui pourquoi pas
l'uniforme quand on va leur demander
d'acheter trois chemisiers blancs et
deux pantalons bleu marine et de les
laver tous les jours pour que les élèves
les aient pour aller en classe ça va
être une autre un autre problème nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que les élèves du
matériel scolaire qu'ils étaient des
vêtements propres adaptés aux
températures qu'ils aient un endroit
pour vivre ou dormir qui soit en
sécurité physique et affective on
rappelle qu'un enfant sur 10 et victime
de violences sexuelles dans notre pays
et comment les élèves sont habillés pour
nous c'est complètement hors sujet voilà
merci nous allons passer à aux questions
des collègues donc nous allons commencer
par Emmanuel Pellerin pour une minute
une minute merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs à l'aune du programme
30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne dans toutes les écoles
primaires de France depuis septembre
2022 je me demande s'il ne serait pas
opportun d'envisager une extension de ce
programme aux élèves des collèges et
lycées
plus précisément l'introduction d'une
activité physique quotidienne dans
l'enseignement secondaire pourrait
contribuer à promouvoir la santé et le
bien-être des élèves a renforcer les
liens sociaux à lutter contre les
problèmes de sédentarité et d'obésité
chez les jeunes ma question est la
suivante
quelle serait selon vous les défis
potentiels et les ressources nécessaires
pour mettre en œuvre une telle mesure et
garantir son succès à tous les niveaux
de l'enseignement tout en intégrant bien
évidemment les contraintes légitimes
liées au temps d'apprentissage et au
programme scolaire merci infiniment
merci Roger judo
un président merci je pense que cette
table ronde est un échec je pense que
l'aigreur des propos tenus
inopérantes ce type de réunion et je
pense madame la Présidente que nos
autres n'ont pas compris où ils sont ni
à qui s'adressent que madame de la FSU
vous nous permettiez d'une faire une
leçon de respect de démocratie est à la
fois ridicule et totalement déplacée le
monsieur du snack ironise sur
l'absentéisme des députés est ridicule
est totalement déplacé donc si vous
permettez je voudrais vous dire la chose
suivante si vous voulez que l'année
prochaine on se retrouve ce qui n'est
pas forcément certain je voudrais que
vous mettiez au niveau au niveau et vous
baissez d'un ton je vous remercie
Sarah le grain
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les élus des
organisations représentatives
j'allais justement dire la honte la
honte que j'ai de voir mes prétendus
collègues vous parlez de cette façon et
vous dire ma satisfaction moi d'avoir pu
organiser cette table ronde il
contribuer comme vice-présidente d'avoir
pu entendre ici tout autre chose que
nous avons entendu ce matin de la part
du digesto et on vous remercie d'être
venu je trouve ça madame la Présidente
je voulais vous dire
légitimé tout à l'heure
nous avons des invités qui s'en vont
parce que vous avez légitimé tout à
l'heure des propos insultants à leur
égard et que vous avez permis ensuite
l'intervention du collège sudo pour en
rajouter une couche et que si on avait
aussi fait respecter le fait de pouvoir
parler correctement si vous pouviez me
laisser parler ce serait bien parce que
là maintenant il y a non non là c'est un
prétexte là on n'a pas fait de
conclusion je suis désolé non non non
non non non non
qui ont été tenus
absolument pas vous nous rappelez non
madame la Présidente
pouvaient dire ce qu'il voulait alors
qu'ils insultaient les personnes
présentes et qu'elles sont toutes en
train de se lever madame je crois que ça
ne s'est jamais produit dans l'histoire
de la commission que vous présidez
jamais produit
est-ce que je peux terminer de parler
merci
donc
je j'ai déjà rappelé à plusieurs
reprises et quand c'est vous qui parlez
la liberté de propos de chacun et si
vous regardez toutes les auditions vous
verrez que vous verrez que régulièrement
je le fais maintenant maintenant que les
syndicats décident de quitter la salle
alors qu'il n'y a pas eu de propos là il
y a des députés qui ont attendu jusqu'au
bout non non non non non non
je
suspends la séance
ça va reprendre voilà donc avant de nous
séparer nous devons procéder à la
désignation de rapporteur sur deux
propositions de loi que nous examinerons
au mois d'octobre sur la proposition de
loi adoptée par le Sénat après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
relative à la restitution des restes
humains appartenant aux collection
publique et j'ai reçu la candidature de
Monsieur Christophe Marion
il n'y a pas d'opposition monsieur
Christophe Marion est désigné
la proposition de loi portant
interdiction de l'écriture dite
inclusive dans les éditions productions
et publications scolaires et
universitaires ainsi que dans les actes
civils administratifs et commerciaux
dont le groupe rassemblement national a
demandé l'inscription à l'ordre du jour
de sa journée réservé le 12 octobre j'ai
reçu la candidature de Monsieur Hervé de
l'épineau que nous accueillons à cette
occasion dans notre commission il n'y a
pas de d'objection les candidats sont
désignés rapporteur donc mes chers
collègues je vous remercie pour d'avoir
assisté à cette séance et je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine